thousands lay dead across the globe face
Twisted into a twitching Rus grin their
corpses are found by their families
their friends and law enforcement but
nobody has a clue what could possibly
have killed them all a serial killer a
mysterious new disease or possibly even
a supernatural monster in all of this
who could possibly expect a rogue meme
before we uncover the secrets of SCP
3078 the foundation would like to
clarify position on the classification
of Cognito hazards you may have seen the
title of this video and worried that we
might be telling you all about an anomal
involving literal excrement but don't
worry this is merely the result of a
precaution we've taken to ensure that
there is no breach of a standard
procedure involving Cognito hazardous
materials to quote the father of modern
toxicology parelius poison is in
everything and nothing is without poison
the dosage makes it either a poison or a
remedy the foundation has categorized
many types of Cognito hazards but we are
not the only organization with rules and
regulations regarding such things to put
it another way there are certain words
and phrases that the YouTube platform
deems Cognito hazardous and must
therefore be avoided lest the foundation
risk its own funding in the name of
accuracy we hope that you understand as
we proceed with that out of the way let
us move on to the menacing mimetic macro
itself SCP 3078 the Cognito hazardous
poop post it's 3:00 a.m. and you're
scrolling through social media checking
on the latest gossip and discourse while
making the rounds to all of the usual
places where you get your funnies in
your late night search you stumble upon
a meme that hits your brain in exactly
the wrong way the joke isn't even that
funny but somehow you begin to laugh
uncontrollably what was it that caused
you to lose your grip was it the
tiredness you were feeling the do drums
of seeing so many UNH wholesome opinions
before encountering the image or maybe
something about the meme was so poorly
constructed that I crossed the line
twice and looped back around to being
hilarious you're not sure and in fact as
you continue to crack up you become even
less sure of what it is that you are
laughing at you try to stop yourself but
the involuntary response continues your
sides begin to hurt and you double over
as tears begin to stream down your
cheeks you cover your face and try to
bite against the insid of your mouth but
there is no stopping the giggle train
the giggle train keeps on rolling
through and your chattering teeth nearly
bite too hard you stop because of the
pain and continue to laugh loudly under
ordinary circumstances you might worry
about waking someone up at this late
hour but as you recall you are
completely alone in the house tonight
there is nobody who would be disturbed
by your seemingly endless burst of
laughter but that only makes what comes
next all the more horrifying by now your
vision is hazy from all the tears of
laughter you can't even see the
offending image that broke your
composure and now the situation is
starting to feel inexplicable that's
when you realize you can no longer
inhale the uncontrollable laughing has
removed your ability to breathe if it
continues like this you will meet an
untimely fate through Suffocation you
are totally alone and unable to call for
help as all the spasms of laughter cause
you to fall out of your chair you RI on
the ground crying and laughing and not
even capable of gasping for breath your
life is fading away all because of a
meme that made you laugh yourself to
death fortunately this is not actually
you but it could have been if you had
been so lucky as to come across an
instance of SCP
3078 unlike most of the unfunny and
low-effort memes that never make it to
truly iconic status this particular
strain of image can have devastating
effects on those who witness it and
that's no laughing matter this is
because despite its apparent poor
quality as a post the humor response it
generates is anomalous in nature and in
every recorded case of exposure quite
deadly to dat SCP 378 has claimed the
lives of
3,576 civilians and two members of
foundation Personnel discovered in the
Untamed wild west of the internet SCP
378 is a self-replicating image that can
appear without warning on message boards
and social media platforms capable of
Hosting media in many ways it is like
any other meme that is proliferated
through the worldwide web with a slight
distinction that it doesn't originate
from a human source for every single
instance of SCP 3078 an anonymous
profile is created simultaneously with a
post on the corresponding platform while
any of these profiles cannot be traced
back to any existing IP address there is
a predictable quality as to when new
ones will spawn though not where er
every hour that an instance of SCP 3078
exists on the internet a duplicate of
the meme will emerge on another website
posted under a new profile the profiles
associated with SCP 3078 share a similar
pattern in that the given username will
invariably be a random arrangement of
the numbers 69 and 420 if these
references fly over your head you are
obviously new to the internet the most
that you need to know is that these
numbers are automatically funny and the
more that they are used as punchlines
the funnier they become in much the same
way as the poop posts they are connected
to 69 and 420 are memes designed to
induce outrageous laughter in those who
witness them when tags and hashtags are
applied to SCP 3078 instances the number
420 is often included as well as the
phrases don't do weed and meeme these
are more coded phrases from the internet
meant to evoke Universal comedy the
phrase don't do weed in particular hints
set a connection to a group of interests
whom we will soon discuss back to the
duplication and generation of the images
there have been theories that SCP 3078
is connected in someway to the
activities of a group of interests known
as Gamers against weed the radical
faction of video gaming enthusiasts is
known for proliferating the danst of
anomalies throughout the world and
several of these have been contained by
the SC CP Foundation you probably
familiar with SCP 3108 the nerfing gun
which reduces any object or living
organism to a worse state that powerful
weapon is a Gamers against weed original
and it is hardly the only SCP that these
Rising upstarts have seemingly brought
into existence most of the other scps
created by Gamers against weed interact
with media and images this includes SCP
2293 which modified pre-existing stories
to include a new line of dialogue at
pivotal moments the line of dialoguing
question will always be did you know
that world-renowned author Stephen King
was once hit by a car just something to
consider while initially meant as a
harmless joke between members of the
group of Interest the mimetic phrase
quickly spiraled out of the gamers
control and began to spread to every
corner of the media landscape incidents
such as these prove that Gamers against
weed has a track record of creating
anomalies that may appear harmless but
cause Untold destruction in their wake
they may not be an outwardly malicious
group of interest but the problems they
cause have serious consequences if the
Cognito hazardous poop posts of SCP 3078
do originate from within the
organization It is believed that the
image was created by a member whose
online handle is harm pit regardless the
post and its duplicates have long since
taken on a life of their own this
duplication process that occurs hourly
while an instance of SCP 3078 exists
is what is known as an SCP 3078 conert
event in order to prevent the spread of
SCP 3078 images every instance of the
post must be deleted to prevent a conert
event from occurring for this purpose a
team of foundation hackers and highly
trained meme experts have been assigned
to patrol the web for any instances of
SCP 3078 and remove them immediately
while this unnamed unit is crucial to
saving lives and keeping your browser
safe from Cognito hazard as material it
would not be accurate to refer to them
as a mobile task force since they are
entirely sedentary in their work but
even without a proper designation our
anomalous hackers have been outfitted
with the latest processing systems and
can also accomplish all their intended
tasks from the comfort of their
top-of-the-line gamer chairs also
Cognito Hazard detecting software and
augmented reality glasses allow our
hackers to safely interact with SCP 3078
without having to use the naked eye in
this way they are safe by avoiding the
memes laughter causing anomalous
properties when it comes to busting bad
memes the foundation hackers are the
Professionals of course our staff is
only able to curtail the number of
exposure cases there seems to be no
known way to reverse the erratic
laughter that results from seeing an
instance of SCP 3078 the only thing
worse than a bad viral meme is a bad
viral meme that kills like a virus too
additionally because memes tend to be
shared in groups and among friends
friends every instance of SCP 3078 has
an indirect KnockOn effect that creates
a cycle of exposure while these Mass
death events caused by SCP 3078 are
usually reported as gas leaks or bizarre
cult rituals the truth on the scene is
often far more gruesome than one might
expect for example before SCP 378 was
cleared from the internet there was a
particularly horrifying event that
resulted from an instance accidentally
being inserted into a slideshow at a
company retreat for a major marketing
firm the second the image appeared on
screen an entire room full of Executives
Specialists and interns burst into an
uproar that continued onward with no
indication of stopping security footage
of the event shows many of the business
associates trying to calm themselves
before looking around and realizing that
everyone in the room was also laughing
the contagious fits of laughter did not
stop and things soon became distressing
the instance of SCP 3078 was not on
screen for most of the duration of the
crowd's laughter but when it had
appeared the text on the top of the
image read when you inhale the devil's
Mary Jane smoke a humorous and trendy
reference to weed the bottom of the
macro featured a distorted Emoji with
deep fried text that read oh no using a
Wayback machine on the confiscated
laptop that displayed the image revealed
that over the course of the Laughing
Outburst the upper text began to change
20 minutes after the laughter had begun
the image read it wasn't supposed to to
be on the slide oh my God this is
embarrassing please stop laughing
everyone 40 minutes later the text on
the SCP 3078 instance changed to no no
no why can't it stop this isn't normal
I'm losing my mind I'm losing it I'm
losing it 1 hour and 35 minutes later
the entire room had completely lost
Consciousness and yet the image changed
again to read it's over it's over we
can't go on like this I never should
have clicked that link
haa that Meme got be dead bro the next
and supposedly permanent change caused
the text to become the letters X and D
next to each other in a text emoji that
repeated 34 times across the instance
there were no survivors and when the
authorities arrived in the conference
room they were alarmed to find that the
victims of SCP 3078 were still laughing
and smiling even though they had already
expired by Suffocation somehow the
anomalous properties that compelled
laughter from those who viewed the
Cognito Hazard persisted after all the
air had already left their lungs raspy
noises of sharp breath forced their way
out of the respiratory system and larynx
of everyone in the room because of the
continued laughter of the corpses
medical practitioners were instructed to
make attempts to save the patients post
exposure there was nothing that could be
done and in a Grizzly image that still
haunts the dreams of some Foundation
staff the morg of the hospital that
attempted to care for the SCP 3078
victims was stuffed with bodies that
were still laughing even while in their
cold lockers amnestics were administered
to everyone involved in the mass
exposure event and efforts to wipe out
all SCP 3078 images were redoubled in
accordance with damages done agents of
the foundation were dispatched to track
down members of Gamers against weed for
comment and possible assistance
compelled if necessary it may not
surprise you to hear that many of the
gww aligned hackers who were caught and
contained during these proceedings were
pressed into Service as conscripted
hackers for the foundation's ongoing web
presence ever since the year 2017 all
known instances of SCP 3078 have been
successfully neutralized long-term
containment is not deemed possible due
to the potential of another image being
posted at any time but when such a time
does arise our teams will be ready to
delete the instance within the hour to
prevent an SCP 3078 Conor event of
course in the years since there was
never a direct admission of guilt on the
part of Gamers against weed or a promise
to cease their activities as a group of
interest but the foundation has been
monitoring The Gamers ever since the
frightening thing about SCP 3078 isn't
so much its deadly consequences but the
fact that it can spread so quickly if
unattended the internet is a very big
and very strange place where any number
of unusual things can happen sure this
Cognito Hazard was new neutralized but
what other mimetic nightmares are
lurking in isolated forums that most
people who use the internet have never
so much as laid eyes upon in the ocean
of data that has existed since the
information age there are dark trenches
where anomalies fester and grow stronger
without the supervision of responsible
adults like the ancient and omniv valent
cthulu from the cosmic horror works of
author HP Lovecraft there are visions of
Madness that mere normies are not meant
to see the worst of them Remain the
objects of worship for select groups of
withdrawn Hermits many of whom will live
their lives in darkness never
endeavoring to feel the light of the Sun
or place their soft uncalloused hands
upon Blades of grass SCP 3078 may have
been detected on the surface of the
internet but only after it spread to
Major social media platforms its
Discovery and neutralization sets a
benchmark for how to handle similar
threats but it would be naive to assume
that the next killer meme will be as
determined to make us laugh it Bears
mentioning that another Gamers against
weed SCP SCP
5273 is the designation given to a kind
of text and image post that can create
irrational anger in those who observe it
if a similar anomaly were to arise that
combined the worst elements of SCP 3078
with SCP
5273 there is a possibility that a
Cognito Hazard meme could be created
that drives the viewer into a murderous
rage while purely theor radical the
foundation remains prepared for anything
by their very nature Cognito hazards are
weapons against the mind and because of
this only the truly Twisted tend towards
creating them or using them consistently
even an entirely sane creator of a
Cognito Hazard may find themselves
corrupted by what they have done and
come to regret ever attempting to change
others Minds in the first place so
remember with or without anomalous
properties memes are serious business
and not to be trifled with without a
proper understanding of the power of
memes a simple harmless idea can spread
on its own and become an unintended
source of mass suffering know your memes
fear your memes respect your memes
burning neighborhoods strings of
horrific Axe Murders a burger joint
selling human flesh and only one
question you mad bro fans of internet
memes from the mid 2000s might remember
number one inescapable image commonly
known as Trollface Trollface and his
trademark grin symbolized mischief and
troublemaking and generally making the
world a more chaotic place over time as
is often the case on the internet new
variations on the image began to spring
up as users created their own spin on
Trollface at first it was all relatively
harmless but then again this is the
internet nothing online stays harmless
forever forever over time more Sinister
variations on Trollface began to surface
memes consisting of joke instructions
that took a dark destructive turn this
new spin on the Trollface quickly became
known as trolia and often featured
disturbing content presented in a joking
prankster format still not something to
be too concerned about just standard
edgy posting trying to get a reaction by
shocking people right not exactly on
December 24th 2020 in Melbourne a
Australia a college student named Lee
Miller received an early Christmas
present from her classmate and
ex-boyfriend Peter witkins the two had
parted on relatively good terms and she
was glad to receive a gift from him when
she opened it she was delighted to see
that he had purchased her a jar of
expensive French facial moisturizer one
she had been interested in trying back
when they were together as she prepared
to do her skincare routine that night
she thought about how thoughtful the
gift was and how sweet Peter was maybe
she'd made a mistake breaking things off
maybe after the holidays she could reach
out and see if they could give things
another shot as she unscrewed the jar of
moisturizer she didn't notice that its
color and smell seemed just a bit off
she just dipped her fingers inside and
began to apply the cream to her face all
of a sudden she realized what a horrible
mistake that was her face began to burn
her skin screaming out in a pain like
none she'd ever felt before she screamed
clawing at her face desperate for a way
to make it stop neighbors heard the
screams and called Emergency Services
when paramedics arrived on the scene her
condition had gotten even worse they
restrained her sedated her and took her
to the hospital for treatment the face
cream was brought in for testing and was
found to have been tampered with it had
been spiked with gimpy gimpy one of the
world's most excruciatingly painful
plants Peter was promptly brought in for
questioning but refused to explain why
he had done it he was charged with
assault and officers inspected his home
for anything that might suggest a motive
on his computer they found the most
recent post he had read before
presumably committing the crime it was a
Trolla meme formatted as a comic and it
read want to get back at your girlfriend
step one find out her favorite facial
cream step two procure the facial cream
step three obtain urien plant use gloves
step four blend the leaves with the
cream then repack it step five give
girlfriend the gift the meme contained a
sixth step but it was redacted in all
official records for reasons that will
soon become clear this incident caught
the attention of thep foundation who
swiftly looked into the meme as a
potential anomaly as they were
conducting their investigation it
happened again another troia meme
another horrible crime with an
inexplicable motive on December 28th
2020 in bond AKA Indonesia 15 terminally
ill patients were found dead in their
hospital beds that wouldn't necessarily
be cause for alarm given the nature of
their conditions except for the cause of
death the patients did not pass away due
to their illnesses instead each and
every one of them was killed by carbon
monoxide poisoning at first the case was
a mystery until security footage
revealed that one of the hospital's
orderly Aziz hiat replaced the patient's
oxygen tanks with tanks of carbon
monoxide he was promptly arrested and
brought in for questioning during the
interrogation he repeated again and
again that he was not trying to harm the
patients but he was delivering them the
police officers asked who he was trying
to deliver them to but he refused to
answer a search through his computer
browser history uncovered another trolls
J meme this one read want to help people
step one get a job at a hospital step
two make friends with the patients step
three enter oxygen tank room step four
four replace tanks with carbon monoxide
step five release them from their
defective vessels the SCP Foundation had
been in the process of formulating a
hypothesis but now it was confirmed
these variations on the troll sheme
contained a Cognito hazardous switch
that would cause a reader to carry out
the acts described in the comic the
switch appeared to specifically be
contained in the conclusive line hence
its removal from all official records of
any identified anomalous memes an ES
imated .25% of those exposed to an
anomalous meme would be affected by this
Cognito Hazard the phenomenon was given
the designation SCP
6661 and the memes themselves SCP 6661
D1 these first two incidents were
nicknamed the pretty girl incident and
the sleepy time incident respectively
several other notable incidents occurred
following the discovery of SCP
6661 on January 20th 2021 the Harvester
Valley incident occurred Oliver dardin
of Alberta Canada packed his bags full
of camping supplies fresh drinking water
a flashlight and an axe he kissed his
wife and children goodbye and he drove
out to the local tourist Campground
after Darkness fell he left his tent Axe
in Hand and walked from Camp to Camp
slaughtering anyone he came across he
managed to kill 10 people and injure 14
before he was killed by the authorities
everyone who knew Oliver was shocked
saying he had no history of violent
Behavior he wouldn't even kill a spider
when he found one inside his wife gave
the authorities permission to examine
his internet activity and sure enough
they found a trolia meme left open want
to have a good holiday step one pack
necessary equipment and items step two
say goodbye to family step three drive
to the valley campgrounds step four find
local Shepherd and his flock step five
steal a little lamb step six relish upon
its flesh for it will be your dying meal
step seven data expunged after reading
the meme the foundation determined that
a nearby farmer was indeed missing one
of his sheep the bones of the missing
sheep were later discovered near the
campground where the attack took place
this new finding suggested that the
Cognito hazardous effects tended to
result in a largely literal
interpretation of the given memes text
Oliver himself could not be questioned
about his actions due to his death on
the scene so there were no more answers
to be uncovered in his case on February
16th 2021 in Bratislava Slovakia a man
named Joseph prasa began displaying
unusual behavior at around 0200 hours he
drove through his neighborhood in his
water truck and began using it to spray
kerosene upon nearby buildings
throughout the area the sound and the
smell woke several neighbors who
attempted to reason with Joseph and make
him stop what he was doing he ignored
them as if in a trance and carried on
with his task frightened for their
safety as well as that of their clearly
unwell neighbor they called emergency
services to the scene Emergency Services
arrived to find Joseph standing in front
of the active nozzle kerosene blasting
directly onto him he didn't even seem to
notice as the authorities approached him
calling out to him asking him to come
with them he acknowledged their presence
he smiled broadly and pulled something
from his pocket all too late they
realized what it was a road flare he
ignited it and the area was swiftly
engulfed in flames 26 people were killed
in the blast and hundreds of thousands
in property damage occurred as a result
that was shocking enough but additional
emergency responders who arrived at the
scene saw something even more bizarre it
began to rain putting out some of the
Flames as the water touched the kerosene
soaked bodies and Landscape paramedics
were completely taken back as they saw
corpses and bits of rubble begin to
float up into the air up into into the
sky one man later described what he had
seen to the police saying it was as if
they were floating on the water that was
falling from the sky the authorities
dismissed this account but the SCP
Foundation knew better this had to be
another trolia incident indeed it was
and on Joseph's computer they found the
guilty meme oil is lighter than water
step one cover yourself in oil step two
feels good step three cover others in
oil step four d
expunged somehow this particular
instance of SCP 6661 had managed to
alter the laws of physics to bend them
to its will it was a troubling
development and not something they cared
to see repeated containment procedures
were swiftly put into place web crawlers
monitored the internet for any
appearances of troia particularly those
that seem to have Cognito hazardous
properties if they could track these
instances and delete them from
circulation perhaps they could prevent
any more needless destruction
during the monitoring process some of
the web crawlers detected an instance of
SCP
66611 with a heavily distorted
concluding step before expunging this
step Junior researcher Mel Ramirez
edited out the Distortion and scanned
the image through a spectrogram
generator this was it should be noted
without prior authorization the
spectrogram generated audio three
recognizable
words Junior researcher Ramirez was
reprimanded for breaching protocol but
his work proved to be valuable enough to
Warrant additional research with the
sign off of the 05 Council a spectrogram
was constructed with a reply to this
question and spread through the internet
the foundation's response was yes we see
you who are you and why are you doing
this within 24 hours of the foundation's
response another SCP 66611 instance with
a similar Distortion was found the
Distortion was isolated and scan through
a spectrogram generator once more it
[Music]
stated people for people forget you man
I am m i the weaker people now like
darkness
andion and bra Shadow chaos strange I
exist people see me
I this Revelation gave the foundation a
new theory on the nature of SCP 6661 the
initial Trollface meme was so popular so
widespread and beloved that the
collective energy directed towards it
created a thought form able to manifest
via the meme when Trollface declined in
popularity over the years the thought
form became desperate to achieve the
same relevance again it gravitated
towards darker subject matter toward the
shocking and disturbing in order to get
attention this resulted in the creation
of SCP
66611 an opportunity for the thought
form to feel seen again when it does not
feel seen when it is not fed energy and
attention the thought form becomes weak
and desperate the Cognito hazardous
effects may not be deliberate at all but
rather an unfortunate side effect of
this particular manifestation an
additional theory was proposed the way
to limit the effects of SCP 6661 D1 to
perhaps even eradicate it is to make the
original troll face popular again the
troll must be fed at first the
foundation was reluctant to put this
Theory into practice it seemed patent
absurd to many of the hups but the
percentage of susceptible individuals
began to increase and more and more
incidents occurred occurred in July of
2021 residents of a small Virginia Town
began to go missing one by one until
over a dozen people had mysteriously
disappeared there appeared to be no
common link between the missing persons
until one unlikely thread surfaced tying
them all together shortly before their
disappearance each person had eaten a
meal at Billy's Burgers the local burger
joint police interrogated all employees
but no new information turned up they
checked security camera footage but only
one of the cameras at the small local
business was operational and it only
captured the restaurant's main entrance
it was beginning to look like one more
Dead lead that is until one of the
investigating officers heard his stomach
Rumble and decided to grab a burger and
fries for the road back at the police
station the officer sat down to enjoy
his lunch taking a big juicy bite out of
his Burger suddenly he felt something
hard crack against his tooth he reached
into his mouth and fished it out had
first he didn't believe his eyes but
sure enough there was a human finger
bone he hopped back in his police car
drove back to Billy's burgers and
demanded to investigate the kitchen
there wasn't anything out of the
ordinary right away but he trusted his
gut and the bite of the burger that he
had almost put it in he confiscated the
freshly ground meat and had it analyzed
the results came back and his stomach
dropped it was human once more the
police officer drove back to the Burger
Joint this time his lights were flashing
his siren was blaring and he was ready
to make an arrest when he arrived the
place was eerily quiet all the lights
were off he drew his weapon and crept
toward the back where he found the fry
cook Jeffrey tombs operating the meat
grinder next to the machine he could
make out bloody scraps of employee
uniforms and suddenly realized why the
place was so quiet Jeffrey was making
his co-workers into Burgers he arrested
Jeffrey and brought the young man into
custody all he would say over and over
again was I'm I made the better the SCP
Foundation caught wind of this
horrifying case and arrived to conduct
their own investigation they found
another Cognito hazardous meme this one
read everyone loves Burgers step one get
job at a burger place step two improve
on the recipe step three Source your own
meat step four profit step five expunged
the foundation attempted to interrogate
Jeffrey as well but he was still not
forthcoming he did say one thing however
he requested that for his dying meal in
prison he'd be given a burger after this
incident the order was given the
Trollface experiment would be carried
out a team of researchers sociologists
and statisticians was assembled and
asked to design images and media
involving Trollface now designated SCP
66612 the images were then disseminated
across the foundation internet
attempting to saturate the media with
this mtic agent until it achieved a
status colloquially known as dank this
team was design ated task force hexa 9
meme machine the initial experiment was
a success and the incidents began to
slightly reduce the all clear was given
and SCP 6612 was disseminated across the
internet again incident numbers
decreased this allowed for standard
containment procedures to be put in
place procedures still in use today the
foundation has established a think tank
to observe the trends and popularity of
SCP 6661 D2 if its popularity declines
the thing tank will evaluate the best
course of action to take SCP 6612 based
mimic agents are to be spread across
various social media sites and the
internet at large as well as the
foundation internet Foundation
webcrawlers must consistently scan the
internet at large for instances of SCP
66611 and look for active SCP 66611
events if any instances are found the
concluding instructions must be redacted
whenever possible any Personnel that is
going to deal directly with SC PP 66611
must be mimetically inoculated before
being assigned to the anomaly oh wait it
seems as though there's one more
mimetically infected comic let's see
here want to see the best videos on
YouTube step one log on step two find
SCP explained step three subscribe step
four ring the bell step five redacted
mobile task force Edna 84 also known by
the code name and thus upon his Crucible
is on one of the strangest missions
they've ever and senton they sit in a
darkened room beads of sweat trickling
down their brows the lights of computer
monitors shine upon their faces they're
tackling a monster that if it escapes
will literally devour all of creation it
has no fear it has no remorse and if it
isn't kept contained by Edna 84 it may
escape and wreck havoc across the world
oh and did we mention it's trapped in a
Minecraft server you heard us right SCP
4335 is a Cognito hazardous
extradimensional being of pure Terror
trapped inside a procedurally generated
world in the immensely popular game
Minecraft you hear about a lot of
horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is
minecraftian there's a lot that needs
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps This truly exceptional
Beast contained the foundation first
discovered SCP 4335 back in 2010 shortly
after the Alpha version of Minecraft was
released because of the online nature of
the game it's proven to be impossible to
contain 4335 externally seeing as it
isn't confined to any one physical
location shutting off the server 4335 is
found in is not an effective containment
method either as this just causes the
entity to Simply hop to a different
server the foundation's greatest fear is
that 43 35 will one day make the leap
out of Minecraft and cause chaos in our
world that's why it's imperative to
draft containment procedures for SCP
4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site M1 the first official
Foundation site made entirely out of
Minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and amnestied since then
Elite SCP Foundation containment
Specialists and Gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for SCP
4335 site M1 is a large Stone complex
built into the side of a mountain it has
a number of key features including a
supply area filled with materials vital
for 4335 continued containment chests
filled with books that contain SCP 4335
containment procedures a few animal
farms for the purpose of breeding and
killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about
4335 if they ever breach containment and
enter the server and of course the
actual containment chamber for SCP 4335
itself which is a little more
complicated 4335 is containment chamber
is built out of several layers all made
from iron blocks the outermost cube is
75x 75x 75 blocks the inner cube is 55
5x 55x 55 blocks and the innermost cube
is 25x 25x 25 blocks creating several
levels of Defense finally one layer
within all these others which contains
the anomaly proper is made from obsidian
blocks SCP 4335 is bound into the center
of the containment chamber with a
complex mechanism the outermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob Farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to SCP
4335 there are even contingency measures
for if SCP 4335 manages to breach
containment if Escape is attempted
blocks of TNT detonate above the ceiling
causing lava to pour into the chamber at
that point MTF Edna 84 are dispatched
into the server to lure 4335 back into
its containment chamber to do this they
fire a mix of fire resistant potions and
ender pearls which have teleportation
capabilities interestingly there's one
more basic method of luring SCP 4335
back into the obsidian Cube taunting and
insulting one of SCP 4335 many anomalous
abilities is being able to hear people
through the screen and being a proud
creature it often responds to insults by
charging in to directly Engage The
insulter if SCP 4335 still manages to
breach the containment that has been set
up for it then they even expect that it
will likely soon hop into another server
at that point the goal will shift to
finding the monster and recontain it
with containment procedures this complex
and extensive it shouldn't come as a
surprise that SCP 4335 rests firmly in
the ker class what exactly is this
anomalous entity why does its
containment hinge on constantly
providing it with items and how did it
end up in Mojang's popular building and
survival game in the first place SCP
4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4334 5 has been
compared to two popular Creepy Pasta
figures Herobrine and the Slenderman but
4335 is far stranger its physical body
behaves similarly to most assets native
to the game with a few peculiar
anomalous abilities we'll discuss soon
handling SC SCP 4335 is an extremely
delicate process if command blocks
creative mode or server commands are
ever enabled in a server with SCP
4335 the server will instantly shut down
and SCP 4335 will move to a different
server SCP 4335 also uses its tendrils
to destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption SCP 4335 grows and when it
reaches sufficient size it hops to a
different server as you can see keeping
a SCP 4335 contained as an uphill battle
but luckily there are two factors on the
foundation's side here the first is that
SCP 4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively Escape Foundation forces the
second factor is that SCP 4335 needs a
rest period between consuming blocks in
order to grow meaning if its consumption
is constant and continuous it isn't able
to grow these two factors have informed
the entirety of the foundation's
containment procedures around SCP
4335 it's locked into its chamber and
fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when SCP
4335 begins to grow the foundation also
found that the application of Ender
Pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however s SCP 4335 does have
a method of striking back against its
captors 4335 is a virgin class
multisensory Cognito Hazard anyone
viewing it without proper training and
protection may experience stressing
hallucinations SCP 4335 is also capable
of telepathic speech with people playing
on its server and as we alluded to
earlier it can also hear any noises you
make while playing weird is a term
thrown around a lot when it comes to
scps considering it's pretty much a
requirement for the foundation to take
interest in you but an all devouring
Minecraft demon that can hear you
talking through your screen is strange
even by Foundation standards MTF Edna 84
first discovered SCP 4335 in the single
player server of Minecraft user leaking
har three team members Jason yelen
Richard Duchamp and sheilia Freemason
covertly entered the game to investigate
and potentially apprehend the creature
when leaking Hart first discovered their
presence on what he thought was a
private server he quickly left a little
creeped out by the sudden intrusion
thankfully the trio was still able to
locate SCP
4335 they discovered the creature hiding
inside a giant crater as though it had
impacted the Earth at considerable speed
Richard Duchamp who was the leader of
the team at the time made the mistake of
looking directly at the entity in that
moment he experienced the full force of
SCP 4335 Cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes in the
aftermath of this incident Duchamp was
taken off the case and Jason yelen was
promoted to head head of the project
things were still going to get stranger
yelon was able to open a dialogue with
the creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and yelson
informed him that had somehow fallen
into the world of Minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this The Entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server yelson and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of SCP
4335 they weren't hurt but they did
appear strange and incoherent After
experiencing 43 35's Cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amn treatment
4335 was contained shortly thereafter
once again yelson came face to face with
his new foe 8 months after being
captured 4335 granted yelson another
interview from containment 4335 admitted
that it almost respected yelson and the
rest of the foundation for figuring out
how to capture and contain it so quickly
in exchange it would give the foundation
something extremely valuable information
first it asked one question of yelson
how does he Define creation yelson
replied uh something that is built and
brought into this universe by a Sapient
being using other things from this
universe 4335 agreed it went on to
explain that it came from a universe
devoid of creation a dark and unknowable
place filled with nothing but violent
random chaos its Dimension existed
directly above ours and it often looked
down at us through a dimension window
fascinated by all the creation below it
plotted and dreamed to one day
infiltrate our reality and yelson
finally had the opportunity to ask the
magic question why though he wasn't
quite ready for the brutal honesty of
SCP
4335 reply I do not like to lie so I
will tell you now I wish to suck it dry
of the toys of whatever Force controls
your universe destroy the light destroy
the Earth and Destroy Humanity it
reminded me of me a blubbering mass of
intelligence and order it sickens me in
ways I cannot
comprehend I hope you understand SCP
4335 was a connoisseur of creation and
it sought to devour all of it in this
moment yelson realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
Minecraft instead of our world which
appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but yelson didn't have time to think
4335 was about to Stage another daring
escape attempt one of its tendrils
reached out and attacked yon's player
character in that moment the real life
yelson began to hallucinate and panic
suddenly back in the game a series of
abnormally tall slender black figures
appeared and began deconstructing the
containment chamber around SCP
4335 it had somehow summoned new minions
into the game to assist in this
Containment Breach Jason yelson entered
Cognito Hazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own game
the foundation managed to find a
solution they contacted Mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
Enderman and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for SC SCP
4335 but there's only one question left
why did the entity fall into Minecraft
rather than our world the file posits
the most likely answer because 4335
defines creation as elements made by
Sapient beings in Minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335 is power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in SCP 4335 is
extradimensional eyes there there is no
creation no intelligent design no
soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic Randomness which is
too unlike its own Dimension so even if
SCP 4335 ever did arrive in our reality
it would likely be disappointed by how
little there is to eat the thin pale
humanoid anomaly had just found itself
in Minecraft of all places the all two
familiar whale of emergency alarms rang
out through the corridors of the
foundation facility it had happened
again another containment breach of
course the on-site Personnel were more
than familiar with the protocols for a
situation like this so well versed in
what to do during an emergency that it
had become second nature whether they
were research staff evacuating for their
own safety or security teams moving in
to recapture the escaped anomaly and get
the situation under control everyone was
moving like they had been programmed
muscle memory taking over the loose anom
was none other than scp096 all
Foundation Personnel were alerted and
reminded not to look directly at the
creature there was just one problem they
couldn't look even if they'd ignored
their order to try nobody could because
the shy guy was nowhere to be found well
nowhere in the real world at least this
whole situation bizarre even by
Foundation standards had all started
with an experiment involving a member of
the Disposable d-class Personnel yet
another dangerous convict serving one of
several life sentences now being used as
an Expendable human lab rat for the
foundation's often Sinister purposes the
experiment in question was an attempt to
further test the limitation of SCP 96's
abilities by now the foundation had done
extensive research into the creature
known as the shy guy they knew its
particular brand of anomalous qualities
were triggered when anyone looked
directly at it being observed would
instantaneously send scp096 into an
uncontrollable rage State causing it to
pursue its Observer until they were no
longer standing scp096 was known to be
able to travel at speed so relentless it
was pretty much impossible to stop one
moment it was sobbing and screeching in
its cell having just been observed and
minutes later the wide jawed long limed
monster was standing behind whoever had
seen it making its screaming face the
image its victim took to the Grave with
them Foundation researchers knew that
scp096 is Rage State could be triggered
by as little as someone seeing the
slightest hint of a creature even if the
shy guy had been captured as a tiny
Speck in the background of a photograph
it would come after anyone whose eyes so
much as glanced over that spec it also
didn't matter how far away the Observer
was scp096 could not be outrun it could
track down anyone wherever they were in
the world but what if a person who had
observed the shy guy was no longer in
the world the experiment had taken a lot
of trial and error after all digitizing
a human being and transforming their
entire Consciousness into code was no
easy task but the foundation wasn't
above breaking more than a few eggs to
make an omelet especially when those
eggs were the brains of a few d-class
Personnel actually the first test
subjects turned out more scrambled or
fried certainly overdone given the
amount of smoke coming from their ears
but eventually the research team had
perfected the device they dubbed the
neural harness a headset that could
translate a person's mind into pure
digital code their Consciousness would
be extracted from their body leaving
their physical form an empty shell while
a digital copy of them was able to
Traverse the local on-site computer
network of course the foundation wasn't
about to let a digitized d-class run a
muuk with their systems so their coding
experts wrote a number of specialized
parameters into their successful test
subject now the digital d-class could be
programmed to follow the foundation's
directive from his perspective it was
like he was floating through cyberspace
towards the system that the foundation
had directed him to a surveillance
camera inside scp096 cell that usually
remained inactive but not today the
camera blinked to life as soon as the
d-class is code-based consciousness
reached it and through it he was able to
observe as CP 096 sitting against the
far wall of its containment chamber
gently whimpering and walking back and
forth that is until the creature felt
that same familiar sensation of being
watched it stood up in raged wailing
uncontrollably as the d-class watched
from within the camera then a split
second later scp096 appeared to Blink
out of existence it hadn't work the
experiment had failed and the digital
d-class began to panic before the
foundation coders could stop him he
frantically scoured the local network
for anything some kind of Escape Route
back into into the real world maybe he
thought if he could get back into his
body it wouldn't count technically his
digital self was separate from his
physical form so he might get out of
scp096 his clutches on a technicality
but it was impossible his body was
already burned out by the neural harness
there was no way for the d-class to
transfer himself back there was only one
option left hide and as it turned out
someone had forgotten to uninstall a
certain building game from a computer in
one of the foundation doctor's offices
the DCL classes digitized mind zapped
him into Minecraft from his point of
view it was like he existed within the
game itself he did a computerized
equivalent of breathing a sigh of relief
only to take back all those ones and
zeros in a horrified gasp as he noticed
a tall wiry framed figure before him it
hadn't worked scp096 had still managed
to follow him into Minecraft even in a
world of computer code the shy guy was
able to dispatch its digital Observer
quite easily and what had once been a
living human mind in the form of binary
code was quickly deleted but that's when
SCP 096 started to take notice of its
surroundings but the most recent person
to see it gone it had the chance to
actually take in where it was the bright
rays of warm light coming down from a
cube-shaped sun reveal a welcoming
landscape all around constructed
entirely from cubes it fascinated scp096
instilling a kind of childlike Wonder in
the shy guy the likes of which it hadn't
experienced since well since it couldn't
remember when rather than leaving
instantly reappearing in its containment
chamber scp096 made the conscious
decision to start exploring there was a
mountainous biome surrounding scp096
Stony spires reaching up towards a clear
sky with a waterfall cascading its way
down the nearest of them at the foot of
the mountains was the opening of a cave
which the shy guy found itself wandering
towards the light from the sun while a
pleasant and welcoming change to the
surroundings it was used to was a little
harsh on scp096 his sunken eyes so
instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves not
unlike the usual darkness of its
containment chamber back at the
foundation traversing through long
winding corridors of stone as scp096
found itself having to bend down to
avoid hitting its head on the Cave's low
ceiling obviously this formation of
Rocky blocks had informed with someone
of the shy guys's height in mind there
was a low Warm Glow coming from the
farthest side of the tunnel and the thin
creature made its way closer and closer
despite the stone walls around it
feeling like a tighter confinement than
its cell approaching the source of the
light SC scp096 was relieved that the
cave opened out into a more spacious
area the cramp tunnel giving way to an
expansive chamber that lay within the
heart of the mountain the warm orangey
glow that had been coming from a flowing
stream of boiling hot lava that seemed
to trickle down from somewhere above
creating a deadly fiery pool directly in
the shy gu's path but just before it
could turn back and leave the cave
through the way he came scp096 sensed
that familiar feeling of something
observing him across the lava pool on
the other side was a creature comprised
of a green Cube for a head with a long
armless cuboid body and four cubed feet
if it had been present in the real world
it might have been made out of leaves
like a living shrub it was staring
directly at the shy guy from across the
lava only for this strange newcomer to
disappear a moment later the creeper
hissed before it realized that scp096
had leaped up behind it to land a fatal
blow but little did the infamously
anxious anomaly realize that the
sentient shrub wasn't done there was a
colossal boom that caused as scp096 to
stagger backwards whimpering at the
sudden loud explosion and the pain that
had accompanied it the creeper had blown
itself to Pieces but in doing so had
left a lasting injury that caused scp096
considerable discomfort as it began
limping towards the cave that led out
the opposite side of the mountain
despite its injury the shy guy was still
able to move with relative ease and the
further it went the more it seemed to
gradually heal however it was as it
stepped out once more into the sunlight
that the creature realized just how
hungry it was back in the real world
World it hadn't eaten for several hours
and surprisingly even while accidentally
stuck in digitized form the hunger
mechanics of Minecraft were having an
effect on scp096 the shy guy started
searching around for anything that could
prove to satiate its hunger there was a
Grove of trees not far so scp096
lumbered to take a closer look it
couldn't be certain but it felt there
was at least a slim chance that there
were apples growing amongst the leaves
but even at the anomaly's own along ated
height it couldn't simply reach up to
pick them however it was while swiping
its arms up at the tree that the shy guy
swung its Fist and knocked at the tree
trunk to the creature's surprise it was
able to chip away at the wood with its
hands punching at the tree until the
trunk had been reduced to a collection
of wooden blocks that the shy guy was
able to collect and sure enough some red
apples dropped from the leaves above
enough to quell the hunger that scp096
was feeling at least for the time being
nearby something was moving through the
trees it was yet to lock eyes on scp096
but the second it did the mob would
surely have sealed its own fate as it
moved around minding its own business
the tall figure overheard the sounds of
the shy guy eating and its attention was
drawn to where the creature was standing
enjoying an apple sensing that it had
been seen as CP 096 turned and locked
eyes with the entity it was perhaps the
only other being in Minecraft that was a
similar height and stature to the
anomaly itself in fact the pair were
strikingly similar before scp096 could
carry out its usual method of attack the
Enderman suddenly teleported out of view
but it was too late now both it and the
shy guy had looked at the other's face
both had been provoked and were
compelled to react in exactly the same
way just as scp096 entered its rage
State the Enderman 2 opened its mouth
and began to shake making loud lengthy
sounds not to similar to the Shy Guy's
own angered scream seems but something
profoundly strange happened next scp096
and the Enderman kept attempting to
pursue one another appearing in a new
location within the Minecraft world
neither one getting close enough to the
other they teleport only for the other
to teleport away the moment they saw
each other each trying to catch one
another but always staying one step
behind this rapid Chase almost became a
strange ongoing sort of teleporting
dance between scp096 and the Enderman at
first the shy guy had been compelled to
attack the Enderman like it was with any
who looked directly at it but as they
appeared and disappeared from place to
place the creature started to feel an
odd kinship with this shadowy fellow it
was so used to being frightened and
alone to its overwhelming feelings of
insecurity and self-loathing that the
Simplicity of just traversing the open
world with a creature very likee itself
in many ways it had all come as a
welcome change scp096 found it
therapeutic tic even and before long was
following the Enderman not out of any
intention to do it harm but just to feel
for a little while like it had a friend
just a little bit longer as CP 096
thought welcoming the enjoyment it felt
playing this game of Minecraft the year
was 2015 Lewis Joseph and Sydney were
like a lot of kids their age which is to
say 11 years old they secretly stay up
past their bedtime watching scary videos
on the internet when their moms and dads
think they're sleeping they go to school
every day and daydream about all the fun
things they're going to do when that
school bell finally rings at the end of
the day and of course they play a lot
and we mean a lot of Minecraft whenever
they're not at school hanging out at the
local park and filming goofy Tik Tok
videos or watching those aention scary
videos on the internet there's a good
chance that they'll be online together
logging a few extra hours building bases
digging big holes or playing survival
mode and seeing how long they can last
against the onslaught of mobs but
there's one particular Pursuit they have
while playing Minecraft together that
takes up the majority of their playtime
one chotic Quest that drives them
forward despite all the naysayers and
doubters tracking down and finding the
legendary Minecraft creepy pasta entity
Herobrine for those who weren't around
on the internet back then creepy pastas
like Herobrine were all the rage like
any video game the new frontier of
Minecraft with all of its procedurally
generated Landscapes felt like it held
new Mysteries and Mysteries are equal
parts exciting and frightening after all
who really knows what's going on behind
a closed door Herobrine was a Minecraft
specific little urban legend stories
told of a default Minecraft skin with
early white eyes manifesting in the game
even in Solo matches and terrorizing
players one internet sleuth who looked
into the mystery of Herobrine claimed it
to be the haunted soul of the Dead
Brother of Minecraft's Creator Marcus
Pon also known as notch in the years
since the legend first started Notch
himself has come forward and disavowed
the claim saying that in fact he didn't
even have a brother and never had so the
rumors were completely baseless but as
we here at the SCP Foundation know the
truth has never gotten in the way of a
good story so Lewis Joseph and Sydney
were happy to remain Believers as long
as they could keep having fun chasing
alleged digital ghosts how could any of
these boys know that in the midst of
their fun they'd run into a real monster
amidst Minecraft's blocky Vistas it was
a school night like any other when they
made that first fateful Expedition it
was 7:15 p.m. and the boys were all in
their shared server Lewis had chicken
tenders Joseph had chicken nuggets and
Sydney who'd eaten his dinner earlier
than the others was snacking on a pack
of Skittles they' all outfitted their
characters with full diamond armor with
diamond swords to match because Joseph
had somehow convinced the others that
diamonds were ghost proof he read it on
the internet he claimed together the
three boys had made themselves an
impressive Minecraft castle to be the
base of their Herobrine hunting
operations a safe haven surrounded by
high stone walls and MOB repel ing
torches to keep them safe if ever they
got a little too spooked while playing
though playing was perhaps too mild a
word for it in the minds of these three
boys they were doing extremely important
investigative work after all if they
managed to actually find Herobrine
themselves they would be creepy pasta
Legends and wouldn't that be worth all
the hours upon hours of rigorous Mining
and crafting they'd been methodical in
their search scoping out different
corners of the map and canvasing them
together searching high and low and then
marking said area off their checklist it
was a level of consideration and thought
that their parents and teachers had long
wished the boys would put into their
home or schoolwork but alas seeing as
none of the homework was find Herobrine
they really weren't that interested
today they were searching an area deep
in the misty forests in the dead of
night they fought off a few spiders and
sword wielding skeletons thankfully no
creepers a man and kept for surging on
into the darkness it's so creepy out
here L said over his headset why do we
have to come out here at night it it's
way more dangerous with all the mobs the
night is like the perfect time for
ghosts Sydney retorted you think a ghost
is going to start hanging around in the
middle of the day no way it's got to be
a night man and LS simply could not
argue with such incredibly Sound Logic
they forged on doing their typical
methodical search for any phenomenon
that one might generously be able to
describe as Supernatural so you can can
only imagine the excitement coursing
through them when Joseph discovered a
strange dark cave that looked as though
it had no business being there while
each held their own private reservations
they all knew what they needed to do go
inside and investigate as they entered
the cave a few strange realizations
occurred to them such as the fact that
there were seemingly no mobs down here a
cave in the dead of night surely there
should be some enemies right plus the
typical lighting implements like torches
and Lantern s didn't seem to offer the
same kind of Illumination that they
normally would it was almost like the
darkness was more oppressive here more
tangible there was undeniably something
Eerie about the whole setup that much
couldn't be denied you guys see anything
LS asked no Joseph said sounding oddly
cautious as though he sensed something
strange was on the horizon something
that perhaps these boys shouldn't see
yeah I haven't seen anything either
Sydney chimed in maybe we should Joseph
screamed and the two others turned their
Minecraft Avatars to look at him
Joseph's character had bumped into
something some stranger in the cave an
NPC design that looked oddly realistic
for something inhabiting the
purposefully lowii blocky world of
Minecraft it seemed to have a dark furry
body with a caned skull-like face
bearing a pair of milky white eyes that
seemed to stare off into nothingness was
this another mob maybe something added
in the latest p hatch if so why wasn't
it attacking what is that thing leis
asked over his headset I don't know
Joseph replied it's so creepy though
suddenly a message appeared on the
screen as though it had been typed and
sent by another player a player with the
username Mal o the message read hey that
isn't very nice you shouldn't judge on
appearances kid that certainly gave them
pause so many things about this didn't
make sense it had all the Hallmarks of
an NPC but apparently it understood
their voices and could send messages it
clearly wasn't actually another player
in a conventional sense but it didn't
attack like your typical mob none of the
boys could really make sense of what
they were dealing with here are you a
hacker Sydney asked no Mal o typed back
I'm just lonely and a long way from home
it's nice to have your company down here
though I don't get visitors often have
you heard of Herobrine Lis asked mow
typed back is he a friend of yours you
should introduce him to me I love making
new friends the three boys were in some
regards rather mature and polite for
their ages and so remained civil with
this bizarre mysterious figure it was
curious and inquisitive asking them
questions about their school lives and
their friends it did seem earnestly
happy for their company so it didn't
give any of them the sense that it was a
threat as night Drew on and the boys
respective parents told them it it was
time to log off and get some sh ey mow
finally typed I've really enjoyed
hanging out with you kids come back and
visit me again tomorrow if you don't
I'll come visit you instead none of the
kids picked up on the probably rather
obvious stranger danger Vibes of this
message and instead they went to bed
excited and curious the next day they
met up on the playground for a kind of
State of the Union on the strange
phenomenon they had encountered the
night before do you think it has
anything to do with Herobrine Lis asked
for forget Herobrine Sydney replied
eliciting gasp from the two others all
the other people have Herobrine we have
something better something only we've
discovered we've got Malo later that
night Joseph who was probably the most
studious of the group tried to do a
little background research on Mal o
everything seemed to turn up dead ends
aside from one slightly Shady looking
app called Mal o version
1.0.0 its description read never settle
for those awkward feelings of being
alone ever again again Malo is an
exciting and interactive experience that
will keep you engaged and intrigued the
anxiety of social situations can be
nerve-wracking but just after a few
hours of Malo you will soon forget all
about those painful emotions of
disappointment be part of the new CCE
that is quickly becoming the next social
substitute remember the more you
participate the more Mal o will engage
you your experience is completely up to
you absolutely no ads enjoy weird so
when unless the thing they encountered
on Minecraft was some kind of weird
viral marketing campaign for the app it
was probably just a coincidence maybe it
was a popular character from Japan or
something by the way for the next
several days the boys honored their
promise they'd visit Mal o in the cave
every night and chat trying to tactfully
get more information out of it though
the best they could get on the entity's
origin was the cryptic statement I'm not
usually here but everyone wants a
vacation once in a while don't they we
can't just spend our whole life on on a
phone they'd become so acclimated to Mal
o over the days that they forgot what
the entity had said to them the very
first day they met come back and visit
me again tomorrow if you don't I'll come
visit you instead but on the day that
they didn't come and visit Malo because
Miss Grayson had sent a particularly
challenging piece of English homework
they received a frightening reminder
that very night they all started
receiving strange texts on their phones
as you can probably respect they were
all photographs each and everyone
depicting some regular haunt that the
boys all like to frequent with one
addition Mal O's grinning skull face
hiding somewhere in the image like some
kind of demented parody of where's Waldo
the strangeness of this new development
left all the boys shaken and they hopped
back onto Minecraft as quickly as
possible to go find and talk to Malo in
its cave however this time the cave was
empty and Malo was nowhere to be seen
but the text still didn't stop it'd come
in so frequently with malow getting
closer to home literally in each one the
boys thought about telling their parents
but would their parents believe them
they probably lumped Mal Owen with the
same Tall Tales of childhood imagination
as Herobrine and write it off as bored
kids playing a prank even though in this
case it was anything but more photos
arrived in these ones Mal o was right
outside each of the children's homes
lurking watching in some of the photos
they could see themselves in the windows
going about their evening business
having no idea of the creature lurking
just outside none of the boys felt like
playing Minecraft that night it wasn't
fun anymore instead they shut themselves
up in their rooms closed and locked
their windows and pulled down the blinds
after checking under the beds with
flashlights of course but still more
photos came in all depicting Mal o
getting closer and closer and closer
closer right about the time they were
wondering whether the scratching on the
outside of their bedroom door was real
or just a figment of their imagination
another dark irony had occurred to them
all this time trying to find something
Supernatural and in the very end
something Supernatural had instead found
them want an anomaly of your own check
out SCP swag.com for highquality SCP
merch ah technology a double-edged sword
of Our Own making that can provide both
ultimate convenience and the threat of a
grim future ruled by unfilling machines
well maybe the stakes aren't that high
yet but our overreliance on technology
can have some terrible consequences the
number of traffic accidents continues to
increase Year bye as our main mode of
Overland Transportation also puts us In
Harm's Way for longer and longer
portions of our day the internet can
allow us to access any information we
may desire but it can spread
misinformation twice as fast and what
about video games an interactive
artistic medium that can provide
simulated experiences so vivid that many
of us can eventually lose interest in
our real lives what starts off as a fun
Indulgence in our favorite hobby can
quickly spiral into an obsession the
risks and rewards of virtual space are
satisfyingly predictable compared to the
chaos of modern living and sometimes we
just can't stop ourselves from striving
for a few more years easy wins minutes
hours and even days can go by without
any apparent activity on our side of the
screen and yet the world of the video
game has changed drastically due to our
actions but at a certain point that
initial Rush of dopamine wears off and
you find that you need a much greater
challenge in order to feel any sense of
accomplishment so you choose to pick up
some harder video games and you grind
away until you can complete them just as
easily but that's not enough either
surely there must be even tougher games
out there games that will never go easy
on you games that won't allow you to
make even a single mistake games that
make you proud of the frankly
inexcusable amount of hours of your life
that you've spent sitting in the dark
clutching a controller squinting at your
screen you need a game that can do all
of that and more and because you've
effectively given up your chances at
ever being a social butterfly you could
also use something to help you mitigate
the overwhelming loneliness that now
constantly defines your everyday life
well worry no longer you weary down
trotted gamer you because here at the
SCP Foundation we've cooked up a
one-of-a-kind mod that is sure to
redefine your gaming experience if this
doesn't turn out to be the game of the
year I don't know what could be among us
to maybe the latest in a long line of
Last of Us remakes what about halflife 3
I digress introducing the foundation's
brand new killer app The Cutting Edge
tactical heuristic algorithms of SCP
1633 combined with the 24/7
companionship of SCP
1471 Mal o I can tell by your expression
that you're already eager for a play
test but slow down we need to catch all
the normies out there up to speed let's
start with the digital K9 companion that
is all the rage SCP
1471 or should I say Mal o version
1.0.0 a euklid class SC SCP object which
comes in the form of a free downloadable
app for your smartphone there has never
been any reviews of this app for as long
as it has existed but honestly are you
really going to trust the words of a
bunch of crooked reviewers when you
could find out for yourself words to
live by don't trust anyone who isn't
part of your precious gaming hobby the
description of Malo version 1.0.0 reads
never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again Mal o is an
exciting and interactive experience that
will keep you engaged and intrigued the
anxiety of social situations can be
nerve-wracking but just after a few
hours of Mal o you will soon forget all
about those painful emotions of
disappointment be part of the new craze
that is quickly becoming the next social
substitute remember the more you
participate the more o will engage you
your experience is completely up to you
absolutely no ads enjoy the app has
never received an update but that's
because
scp-1471 has been a completely
functional experience since its release
all one needs to do is download the app
and within a matter of hours Mal o
version 1.0.0 will begin to send the
user photographs of familiar locations
these can include photographs of the
user's work home or public places they
often frequent such as cafes and
nightclubs in the case of you a complete
shut in gamer these photographs would
probably be limited to the interior of
your favorite gaming room when was the
last time you cleaned up those pizza
boxes regardless of where the images
were apparently taken each one will
contain a canine humanoid with a skull
for a face say hello to your new best
friend Mal o or scp-147 71-a if we're
using the approved designation Mal O's
app will continue to send you
photographs for as long as you have it
installed and because there is no way to
uninstall it no matter how hard you try
you'll be getting intimately close to
home selfies for the rest of your days
doesn't it feel so good to have such a
loyal friend as Melo of course there's
only so much you can gain from
photographs alone you're a gamer damn it
and what you want is interactivity but
don't worry about that part we've got
you more than covered with SCP
1633 which may in fact be the most
challenging video game ever programmed
by mortal hands hell it even gives many
Games programmed by anomalous hands a
run for their money while it was never
released to the market and doesn't even
have a working title the steampunk
Adventure that awaits you within SCP
1633 is bolstered by highly
sophisticated tactical heuristic
algorithms in this third person
squad-based action RPG you can switch
between four playable characters The
Marksman who specializes in longrange
Weaponry The Alchemist with potions and
chemicals to control the battlefield the
Rogue a stealth oriented character who
catches enemies unaware and assassinates
them and of course the thug a tough as
Nails melee combatant with increased
health and durability it doesn't really
matter who you choose because most
playthroughs of SCP 1633 always end the
same way that being said your hand eye
coordination and reflexes are second to
none and they also are quite possibly
your best qualities let's set you up
with the Marksman as your main character
since all those Shooters you've played
will definitely help your aim and trust
me you're going to need it the story
mode of SCP 1633 will put you up against
a slew of Victorian era Rascals and
miscreant all of which are pulled
straight from the penny dreadfuls
there's even some class fantasy races
mixed in from the works from Good Old
Professor tolken himself dwarves elves
Goblins the works it's a little generic
but why worry about the story when the
game play is what will really get you
hooked there's a final boss at the end
of the game known as the kraar trying to
destroy the entire world you need to
stop it you know the usual RPG storyline
you've stopped dozens of ancient
entities demon Lords corrupt godlings
and unspeakable calamities in your time
this Kar will be one more for the record
books par for the course are you ready
player one you'll be dropped straight
into the marksman's shoes fighting for
her and your life against kar's hordes
of henchmen but you won't be doing it
alone After all you've got the rest of
your squad and a mysterious companion
whose true intentions will reveal
themselves in due time we did say we
modded the game after all so let's play
your first 2 hours won't be anything to
write home about no not that you ever
leave home these days the AI of SCP 1633
will seem to be barely functioning a
buggy mess where enemies only charge in
a straight line towards your character
your marksmen will be easily able to
take them down in the hail storm of
projectiles at 3 hours in things start
getting a bit more interesting as the
Tactical heric algorithms kick in the
enemies that hold longrange weapons will
shoot at you from a distance while the
close-range ones will move toward you in
a serpentine pattern pattern before
attacking in melee this is more like it
not the most challenging but the game is
clearly increasing in difficulty you
also think you see a dark figure with a
skull for a face lurking around corners
and following your squad but with all
the glitches it's hard to tell if this
is an intentional part of the game or
not at 5 hours enemies that showed
limited signs of strategy are now using
cover effectively and will attack with
alchemical Splash weapons such as
grenades to deal damage to your r Ed
characters and lure your squad into
melee range they still aren't that much
of a challenge but the fact that they
now exhibit a clear self-preservation
Instinct means that they are fighting to
win this is also when your help
officially arrives you're in the middle
of a shootout when you see an enemy
about to throw another one of those
frustrating Splash weapons you duck
behind your cover and prepare to take a
hit when suddenly the grenade is
snatched out of the enemy's hand and
tossed in the opposite direction ction
to explode harmlessly this is the work
of SCP 1471-a who has now arrived in the
game world as an NPC Ally for the next
several hours of gameplay ma o continues
to provide interference by preventing
any Splash weapons from being thrown
it'll sneak up on enemies and take their
weapons disrupt their cover by pushing
movable boxes and trash cans out of the
way and even catch the splash weapons in
her mouth like a dog would catch
frisbees before chucking them away
while it never directly deals damage to
the enemies its mischievous Antics are
very efficient at protecting you from
harm as luck would have it the enemies
can't seem to interact with Mal o and
are baffled as this invisible force
continues to throw off their strategies
Malo will use this to its Advantage as
well as yours by appearing at enemy
Ambush points and using sign language to
communicate warnings to you as the
player having Mal o around starts to
feel a little bit like cheating
but keep in mind the game is starting to
adapt to your skill level and will soon
begin to employ Advanced strategies to
mess with you all the Malo mod does is
even the playing field Kar is still
running rampant in the world of SCP
1633 and it's going to take your entire
Squad of Steampunk Heroes and a lonely
Man's Best Friend Mal o to stop this big
bad evil guy the final boss will possess
the highest level of intelligence that
the algorithms are capable of of and
it'll make that known to you the second
you step into the arena for the majority
of your game play the enemies have
focused on countering the Marksman since
you've relied on that character's ranged
weapon style but they've come to realize
that that you're too much of a pro MLG
gigachad to ever lose a fair encounter
so karnar does the unthinkable and
targets The Alchemist Rogue and Thug
First it throws all of its most powerful
attacks at the members of your squad you
aren't controlling forcing you to waste
resources in order to keep them alive or
switch to them in order to dodge fatal
blows whenever you aren't in command of
the Marksman kathar will strike the
character with a strong melee attack
that forces you to take control back
Malo is still unable or unwilling to
deal damage to the boss so it very much
seems like you are on your own your
squad is in shambles your focus is
starting to wne after all that you've
been thrown in this gaming challenge it
might be the final boss that makes you
throw in the towel then a dialogue box
appears it's from Mal o don't give up
hope user I've had so much fun playing
with you and I know that you have what
it takes you never needed a friend
before me and you can win against
craftar just like you won against every
other final boss you've ever faced
you've got this buddy your best friend
Mal o it felt overly sentimental but
something about this message fills you
with the determination to to keep going
you call upon all your gaming knowledge
all of your skill all of your passion
and with pinpoint Precision you guide
your squad to defeat cnar in
record-breaking time you sit back in
your gaming chair exhilarated and
finally satisfied This truly was the
ultimate gaming experience and all you
needed was a Little Help from your
friend God damn it the comment section
on this one is going to be hell
do your worst you filthy
animals now before we begin today's
video let's clear some things up we know
exactly what you're thinking and among
us as CP this sounds ridiculous why
would the foundation ever have to deal
with an anomaly relating to Among Us of
all things is this some kind of sick
joke dreamt up by our YouTube commenters
and look we get it it's definitely one
of the more ridiculous anomalies the
foundation has has had to contain at
least at face value but there are a few
things you should take into
consideration before things get to a
mugus pilled around here oh God first
this is hardly the strangest anomaly
we've covered on as SCP explained SCP
5981 also known as nuke City revolved
around a mysterious broadcast of a
Family Guy episode SCP 4335 a wel in The
Crucible had to deal with an entity
occupying space inside the video game
Minecraft but there are countless other
examples of anomalies creeping into
popular culture mutating it and twisting
it for their own purposes what may seem
silly on paper such as the foundation
having to do research on a popular video
game like Among Us is all part of what
the organization does if the brave
researchers at the SCP Foundation
chuckled and brushed off a Potential
Threat just because it had to do with
something like Among Us the entire
population might be susceptible to a
supernatural event of unprecedented
proportions the foundation's entire veil
of secrecy could crumble all because
someone Shrugged off the possibility of
allocating resources to deal with a
threat millions of civilians could
discover these games movies and shows
are all immensely popular and an anomaly
affecting a global phenomenon like among
us could spell Doom for not only the
foundation but the entire world as well
if left unchecked so if you don't want
to risk termination please try to keep a
straight face as we divulge into the
weird and wacky story of SCP
5167 an anomaly camed in the
foundation's database
as when the impostor is sus oh God I
hate my job sometimes to begin we need
to go back way way back centuries before
Among Us was even conceived as a concept
before video games had been invented and
even before electricity itself was
discovered back to an Era where the gods
of Olympus ruled Supreme and stone
marble statues line buildings that would
serve as Timeless Feats of architecture
and where a new school of thought was
developing one that focused on logic and
reason instead of superstition and
hearsay that's right we're talking about
ancient Greece a society that for all of
its achievements and progression in the
fields of Education cultures and logic
was still largely governed by religion
and mythology but of course as you may
come to Expect When dealing with the SCP
Foundation there's always a little truth
in that which we cannot understand while
those who are unaware of the Paranormal
might deride the Greeks for being overly
focused on a Pantheon of gods they
logically should have no reason to
believe those who know that anything can
happen in the world of the anomalous may
approach this topic and the subject of
religion in general in a different light
the Greek gods were very real while the
myths may not be entirely true and they
may not have been literal Gods there
were a group of anomalous entities who
influenced Greek society performing
miraculous Feats that left those who
observed them in complete wonder and
putting together Cults of worship
surrounding them while most of this was
done in secret word of these beings
traveled incredibly fast in the ancient
world and they were heralded as Gods
beings of divine might that could do
anything in the universe who existed
above the Mortal plain and demanded
worship from their followers a glance at
Greek mythology paints a picture of a
group of gods who acted more or less
like humans they fought they killed they
argued and they felt human emotions it's
likely that this characterization in the
stories emerged from how these entities
conducted themselves in actuality there
were dozens upon dozens of entities the
Greeks worshiped as Divinity and while
the stories portrayed the gods as
jealous vengeful beings who constantly
fought with each other it doesn't
compare to the reality of the situation
which was much more Cutthroat you see
there were 12 gods of Olympus and you
probably know most of them there
remembered today for a reason Zeus
Athena Poseidon Aries the list goes on
we still remember these beings because
of the iconic stories they took part in
and how significant they were in ancient
ient times while for every Zeus god of
lightning there were five more Gods who
absolutely no one but the most hardcore
historical fanatic remember gods of
Niche subjects who had small followings
who never had those character defining
myths to flesh them out and preserve
them for all of history to remember who
would when Greece fell Fade Into
Obscurity for every Zeus there was a
pythius who was pythius you ask well if
the guy heard you asking them question
he'd probably Smite you down before the
question even left your lips if he
wasn't engaged in a hardcore game of
Among Us that is don't worry we'll get
there all will be explained it's the
name of the channel after all fonus was
a god of jealousy and envy mainly in a
romantic context do you have a crush on
someone who's already taken phonus knows
all about that do you wish you weren't
trapped in a dead-end relationship with
someone who doesn't love you tonius
understands your plight but tonius
wasn't just a reverse Bizarro Cupid he
was a literal personification of the
emotions of jealousy and envy themselves
no matter the context if it was petty
and greedy thonus knew it all too well
you would think that this would make
thonus a prime candidate for some
mythological drama right after all the
Greek gods loved their infighting and
who better to stir up some Hara said
Zeus said arguments than a literal God
of Envy well it didn't quite work out
that way for thonus his appearances and
myths were infrequent and today he is
nearly all but forgotten reduced to a
mere three sentences on a Wikipedia page
while other figures from his era have
taken on an entirely new life in the
modern day as cultural icons like
Perseus or Hercules but no poor thonus
whose pension for jealousy and envy
backfired on him and catapulted him Into
Obscurity why did this happen it's kind
of obvious when you think about it while
other gods granted their worshippers a
good harvest or copious amounts of wine
and partying all thonus had to offer was
well the ugly side of humanity his
worshippers were far and few between
after all no one wanted their entire
life to revolve around the jealousy of
others and thonus being a
personification of Envy had an
understandably difficult time getting
people to devote themselves to him
thonus was greedy and envied the other
gods so while he would accept nothing
but absolute worship from his followers
he couldn't offer much else especially
not when compared to the Bountiful Boons
a great God like Zeus or Hera could
offer and so thonus festered an ugly God
who wallowed in self-hatred and
irrelevancy constantly living in the
shadow of the pantheon that gave him
purpose and his purpose was to remain
jealous to remain envious of those who
have
what he did not a god unfit to be
worshiped whose purpose was to embody
the feelings of wanting what isn't yours
thonus is both tragic and poetic and
when the Greeks faded away so too did
thonus the Roman Empire who largely
adapted Greece's Pantheon of gods for
their own stories left no record of
bringing thonus into the mix for
centuries he was a god without a home
attempting to find a place in a changing
world thonus was angry jealous envious
and tired the forces of the universe
would call him forth in every new era
thrusting him back into the world and
forcing him to search for the sustenance
beings that were referred to as Gods fed
off of devotion but every time thonus
would find himself walking the earth
once again he would instead discover
that there was no place for him mankind
was moving on there was less and less
room for Gods with every passing Year
all the popular ones had a established
themselves as Everlasting religious
figures at this point and they would
never fade away some took pleasure in
living among humans rising to power as
people of influence and fame others who
could not find a place in the world
would Fade Away Never to be revived or
worshiped ever again Forgotten Dead Gods
who the world long outgrew but thon's
jealous Spirit would never allow him to
consign himself to that fate he hated
who he was and what he stood for but
that nature brought him back so many
times before it was his jealousy of the
other gods who were somehow managing to
linger beyond their Greek Heyday that
caused him to persevere he needed a
purpose one last chance to be remembered
he had struggled for centuries and this
was his last ditch effort to be
remembered wherever he would wake up in
the modern era thonus would have to make
the most out of it and this is where
Among Us comes in in late 2020 the SCP
Foundation was just as captivated as
anyone else by the Among Us phenomenon a
game that was sweeping the globe where
players took on the roles of crew mates
on a spaceship one of which was an
impostor whose job was to secretly
murder the other players while they were
busy doing tasks that range from
scanning themselves in the medbay OR
scanning key cards in the admin room the
impostor would be lurking behind every
corner sometimes in the ship's air vents
waiting for the proper per moment to
strike if a dead body was found a player
could report it and the players would
then discuss which one of them they
suspected to be the impostor the game's
addictive psychological elements and
accessible rules made it a Smash Hit but
for the foundation they were infatuated
with it for entirely different reasons
you see when a piece of media attains
the level of Fame that Among Us did the
foundation has to make sure to keep
their eyes on it popular media is a
prime target for anomalies the popular
A's Collective attention on it just
seems to invite the forces of the
supernatural world to warp and distort
what we know to be familiar and this is
exactly what was happening to Among Us
for months the foundation was
documenting cases of an entity who
appeared in games of Among Us and caused
havoc in the real world these cases and
their after effects were so severe that
the foundation deemed the anomaly
significant enough to get its own file
in the database designating it under the
name SCP
5167 SCP 5167 would join games of Among
Us like any other player they would
blend in much like the impostor in the
game and play just as anyone else would
it was what happened after a player
participated in a session with SCP
5167 that had the foundation
investigating every aspect of the game
those who played with SCP 5167 would
find themselves stricken by a severe
case of paranoia and cap grass delusion
a psychological condition in which a
victim would come to believe those
around them had been replaced with
identical imposters the severity of this
disorder varied between individuals but
some believed the delusions to such an
extent that they lashed out at those
they believe to be imposters sometimes
resulting in a homicide naturally the
foundation put two and two together
which led back to Among Us after several
months of police cases relating to
completely average IND individuals
suddenly striking out at their loved
ones sometimes killing them and showing
signs of capg grass delusion the
organization knew that something was
happening on an anomalous scale at first
it was difficult to make the connection
to among us but the foundation
eventually learned from interviews with
victims and an examination of their
habits over the past few weeks they had
all played the game and through analysis
of the Among Us community's various
Trends and habits the foundation
discovered SCP 5167 an entity that was
slowly gaining notoriety within the
games Community as an almost
mythological figure SCP 51 67's tendency
to spout long wordy rants at other
players during the game's emergency
meeting sessions position them as an
inside joke for those who encountered
them needing to establish a link between
these anomalously induced spouts of
paranoia the foundation set up a group
of WebCrawler AIS to track Among Us game
sessions until SCP 5167 would appear it
was a long shot but it was one of the
many different theories on why these
victims were undergoing this level of
psychosis and if it proved to be true
then the foundation would have a solid
idea of what to do next after weeks of
nothing SC SCP 5167 was spotted in a
game and the foundation acted quickly to
track down the other players who played
alongside the entity naturally they
exhibited signs of paranoia and delusion
some of them only for weeks and others
for months that was enough evidence for
the foundation would later document
several other occurrences of games with
SCP 5167 resulting in these psychiatric
conditions in other players the
foundation did what they do best and
established a series of special
containment procedures that would wipe
SCP 5167 from the internet as best they
could web crawlers were trained to take
down any mentions of the entity and if a
potential sighting was discovered the
foundation would investigate any and all
players involved in the incident anyone
affected by SCP 5167 would be held under
the guise of receding medical treatment
for mental health issues and they would
be amnesticized completely you might be
thinking that the after effects of SCP
5167 are relatively tame compared to
what the foundation usually deals with
but look at it this way Among Us is a
game played by millions of people if SCP
5167 affected only a fraction of that
population it would spell total chaos
for the foundation not only that but the
amount of Bloodshed The Entity would
cause would be nothing to scoff at as a
large amount of cases dealt with victims
outright murdering anyone they suspected
to be an impostor attempting to track
down the SCP 5167 entity were met with
failure All Points of internet access
that the foundation was able to get
their hands on only led to a series of
abandoned home addresses in rural Greece
but over time things started to change
the the foundation began to place less
of a concern on SCP
5167 it was almost as if the entity was
being forgotten why this letter
addressed to the SCP 5167 research team
from the site's director might clear
some things up as requested by head
researcher Abrams I've had the site 22
analyst look into the progress of SCP
5167 anomalous effects over the period
we've observed it and the results are
much as I expected when we first
discovered SC P 5167 for the sake of
argument let's say this is when SCP 5167
first came into existence the impact it
had on its victims was severe I don't
think I have to remind you of what Billy
Heath did to his family's faces but
since then almost immediately really
since that first couple of
manifestations the potency of its
effects have started to decline full
Detachment from reality became delusion
and delusion has now become paranoia and
the intensity of that paranoia is
lessening in each new case this is all
conjecture of course and shouldn't be
taken as gospel but based on what we've
observed of this anomaly thus far our
estimation is that SCP 5167 anomalous
effects will become a note by the end of
the year whether it'll keep popping up
in these video game matches is another
story though it was just as the Director
had explained SCP 5167 cases were
becoming less severe they were almost
becoming irrelevant so much so that the
foundation hypothesized that the
anomaly's declining potency would lead
to its neutralization before long an
entity Fading Into irrelevance and
obscurity once more if you haven't
figured out yet maybe SCP 5167 username
will spell it out for you when the
entity joined gains of Among Us it made
sure that everyone knew who it was well
everyone would know who it was if the
entity had managed to maintain any form
of popularity over the past dozen
centuries or or so that's right SCP 5167
would join under the name thonus the
God's New Life had thrusted into the
modern day except this time it was
inside the game of Among Us where it was
forced to cope with the reality that the
world seemed to be more obsessed with a
trendy game than any God or mythological
figure while inside the game thonus was
one bitter individual during emergency
meetings instead of trying to figure out
if red was sus or not the god would just
yell at the Players around him one
player asked thonus what they were doing
while the rest of the crew was
performing their tasks to which thonus
poetically responded where was I I was
there when the mountains were newborn
and the oceans virginal I was there when
Gods walked among men and their wisdom
was cast down like sunlight I was there
when mankind was capable of Legends and
now I find myself in a world that has
forgotten even the taste of life even
the very concept of Life Beyond not
existing from one day to the next mere
continuance where all the world is
wasted away an idle play of emotions
that once rang true I am in the world
where even the gods are forgotten their
bones washed away by time a world where
man has moved on where all the Legacy I
have left are all three sentences on
Wikipedia I thought my time had come
again I thought this could be the new me
but this is nothing let me stay dead
this time
I'm tired to which the other players
responded in typical Among Us fashion
that thonus was sus he was promply voted
as the impostor and ejected from the
airlock and so the tragic tale of thonus
came to a close a tired obscure God who
never had a place in the world his
presence in Among Us grew less and less
as the game's popularity waned and once
again he would Fade Into Obscurity but
the nature of thonus meant that he would
in some form return again one day where
or how no one could say but as long as
there was a situation to reap Envy from
a trend to be jealous of thonus would
remain eternally doomed to suffer the
fate of being nobody's favorite God and
frankly we can't imagine this video will
change that video games have come a long
way over the years we've gone from the
days of Atari and pong to Virtual
Reality headsets ps5s and massive
multiplayer online games where you can
fight horror movie villains or wage war
in a fantasy land you can mine virtual
minerals and avoid creepers in Minecraft
compete against people all over the
world in fortnite and do whatever it is
people do in Roblox games used to be a
pixelated hero battling Blobby monsters
with no discernible facial features and
now they have Graphics so detailed you
can see the freckles on a protagonist's
face and each individual blade of grass
but there's one thing that hasn't
changed
no matter how much progress games may
make whenever a shiny new console comes
out everyone wants to get their hands on
it it was Christmas season in
1986 Walk Like an Egyptian by the
Bengals was at the top of the charts
Eddie Murphy's The Golden Child was the
number one movie in America and hundreds
of thousands of kids were writing to
Santa and begging their parents for one
thing the Nintendo Entertainment System
the NES was an 8-bit home video game
console and the only place to Journey
Through the land of Hyrule in The Legend
of Zelda or help Samos hunt space
pirates in Metroid but with such an
extreme demand for the system stores
were selling out all over the country
anyone who didn't beat the crowds was
doomed to disappoint their kids with
socks with less flashy toys like dolls
or tiny plastic trucks or with boring
non-electric violence-free board games
well board games are only violence free
if you're not playing Monopoly but back
to
1986 Beverly Harrington was a single mom
doing her best to provide for her son
Jason and give him the Christmas he
deserved she had been picking up extra
shifts at the local Diner making sure to
save up all the extra money for a real
Christmas tree from the farm just out of
town for a beautiful HoneyBaked Ham and
of course for presents she knew that
though he was a shy kid and would never
demand it Jason desperately wanted to
find an NES under the tree on Christmas
morning she got so absorbed in her work
so exhausted from the extra shifts and
trying to make everything perfect that
she forgot to do her actual shopping
until the very last minute she woke up
the morning of December 24th with a
start her heart jumping into her throat
she hadn't picked up Jason's present yet
she threw on her coat and rushed out
into the snowy streets making her way to
the store and saying a silent prayer
that they would still have one more NES
in stock lucky for her they did less
lucky two parents were already wrestling
for it fighting each other with a raw
animalistic Rage of two wolves competing
for the same piece of meat if she tried
to grab it and join in she could get
hurt or the console could break apart
she asked an employee if they had any in
the back but she already knew the answer
from the exhausted look in his eyes
there were no more in the back there
were no more in town nor the next town
over or the next town over from that not
only would she have to get Jason's
present at the very last minute but she
would also have to get him something he
didn't even want he would smile and
thank her but she knew how sad it would
make him to go back to school and hear
his friends bragging about their
Christmases she shoved her hands into
the pockets of her coat and began her
slow sad March back through the snow
trying to come up with what to do next
then something caught her eye a brightly
colored sign reading Wonder taining toys
beneath it it was a storefront she had
never seen before and right there in the
window a video game console it wasn't
the NES not exactly
but it looked so much like it she
couldn't help herself she had to go
inside and get a better look the store
was filled with toys games and puzzles
they were all inviting with Vivid
packaging and labels depicting children
having fun but she had never seen any of
them before perhaps it was a new brand
and she was one of the first people to
happen upon the store it seemed odd for
a toy store to open this close to
Christmas rather than taking advantage
of the shopping season and opening
earlier in the year but she couldn't
dwell on that not when she was this
close to a solution toward the back of
the store she spotted the video game
console from the window the label read
pretendo so the resemblance to the NES
was no coincidence this console was
intended as a knockoff of some kind she
asked the sales clerk a man with a
strangely wide unmoving smile if the
console was capable of running Nintendo
games you bet your bottom dollar he
replied we don't carry those here though
but can I interest you in some of our
wonderment Originals we have all kinds
of games here and they're just as good
or your money back there's a whole world
inside each and everyone it wasn't what
she'd set out to buy but this was
clearly the best thing Beverly was going
to find this close to the holiday she
paid the man for the pretendo console
and a selection of the store's most
popular video games he even gift WRA it
for her in a colorful box with a shiny
red bow on top the next morning Jason
and Beverly sat in the living room
sipping cocoa and opening presents
together she started small with a
classic pair of new wolf socks and
worked her way up to the big box in the
corner as Jason tore the paper off his
eyes lit up with Glee thank you Mom
thank you he gave her a huge hug then
looked at her with nearly manic
excitement can I play it now can I she
laughed and promised that after he
helped her clean up the wrapping paper
he could play his new games she was just
so glad he was happy with it he didn't
care that it wasn't the name brand
console he knew that this gift was
special so she was perfectly glad to let
him enjoy it and she could get started
on that ham for later Jason plugged in
his brand new pretendo and looked
through the games his mom had picked out
for him there was farmtastic Farming
Simulator Historical house Hunter magic
Wizard Quest super Fighters and one
simply called spooky it was emblazoned
with the image of a cartoon ghost in
front of an abandoned cabin and it
peaked Jason's interest he always loved
scary stories and legends about ghosts
and Things That Go Bump in the night he
decided that this would be the first
game that he would play he placed the
cartridge in the console and hit the
power button to turn it on as he
clutched the controller in his hands he
began to notice something strange his
room once decorated in posters of his
favorite movies turned dark the light
green Walls became rotting wood and for
lack of a better way to describe it the
entire world's resolution began to shift
if the world around him had Graphics
they were getting worse he could no
longer see the screen depicting the
game's main menu and in fact fact the
console itself had vanished somehow he
was standing in the Haunted Cabin from
the cover of the game he looked down at
his hands and found the controller still
there so not everything had changed
before he could think anymore about this
strange new place he found himself in he
heard the sound of ominous music
seemingly coming from nowhere after a
moment he realized why the sound of its
Melody filled him with dread it was the
kind of music that always played in a
game when an enemy was getting close
he had to move he took a step forward
and moved through the space as if it was
a real house for the time being it was
somehow he was inside the game which
meant the ghost was coming for him soon
he pressed a button on the controller to
activate a flashlight and followed its
beam through the darkened cabin as he
walked looking for clues or any object
he could interact with he could hear the
music getting louder whatever was coming
it was getting closer the flashlights be
beam illuminated the scrap of paper on a
small table he moved to take a closer
look and could just barely make out what
it said they hide in the darkness find
the exit don't stop moving he heard a
sound behind him and the music reached a
deafening volume he Whirled around and
saw nothing but the hall in front of him
bending around a corner he knew from the
heavy feeling in the pit of his stomach
and the music that threatened to rupture
his eardrums that there was something
horrible waiting for him around that
corner he froze for a moment then
remembered the Letter's words of warning
don't stop moving he took a step towards
the corner then another and another he
shown the light of the flashlight around
the corner but there was nothing there
no ghost no monster nothing and then he
felt it a chill on the back of his neck
he Whirled around and there it was the
Ghost of the cabin it was so much bigger
than it had looked before wispy white
form stretching up to the ceiling from
wall to wall its wide dark eyes and
gaping ma of a mouth inches from his own
face he screamed and instinctively swung
the flashlight at the Spirit cutting
through it with a beam of light the
ghost let out a shriek and shrank away
from the glow that was it he just needed
to keep the light on it and the ghost
couldn't hurt him Jason was so thrilled
by this little victory that he didn't
even notice the Boss music starting to
play again growing louder and louder he
didn't see the movement out of the
corner of his eye the Silvery pale
figure of a woman stepping out of a
portrait on the wall all he felt was a
sudden overwhelming cold like ice in his
veins and then everything went black he
opened his eyes back in his bedroom
looking at a dark screen with the words
game over written in dripping red font
he couldn't tell for a moment if that
had been real or a dream but either way
he only wanted to do one thing tell his
mom Beverly listened to her son's story
and couldn't help but write it off as
the overactive imagination of a child
but still she humored him and agreed to
try the console for herself and see what
happened choosing at random she selected
farmtastic and pressed play all of a
sudden she felt the heat of the sun on
her face heard the mooing of cows and
smelled fresh cut hay she was steering a
tractor through a wide open field where
a moment ago she had been standing in
her house in the dead of winter Jason
shut off the game pulling her back into
reality and as Beverly gasped in shock
Jason said best present ever
unfortunately for Jason word was already
spreading about the pretendo all the way
to the SCP Foundation the console and
all other consoles that the foundation
could track down were seized and
designated SCP 591 SCP 591 is a line of
video game consoles originally developed
as a counterfeit of the Nintendo
Entertainment System before being bought
and distributed by Dr Wonder tainment a
toy company responsible for a wide
variety of anomalous objects contained
by the foundation over the years the
console is capable of playing NES titles
as well as games from Dr wain's original
lineup of 8bit games many of which the
foundation has in its possession as well
some of the titles in the SCP
foundation's Library include but are not
limited to Arcade shooter wam platformer
Dusky adventures in stateand survival
horror game can do that on television
puzzle game World War I Ace trench
digger music racing game lead Zeppelin
Air Racers fighting games super kit
karate and super kit karate 2010 and the
educational game Reading Rainbow sit and
listen whenever one of the official dror
wondertainment cartridges is inserted
into the console and activated it
results in a localized CK class reality
restructuring scenario which rearranges
reality in the immediate area to
resemble the game's settings the player
inside of the game's affected radius
will take on the role of the game's
protagonist and navigate the events of
the game until either they win or the
console is deactivated don't worry this
isn't one of those if you die in the
game you die in real life scenarios if
the player happens to be a less than
Adept gamer they will simply respawn or
start at the beginning of the game like
any video game character would that
doesn't however mean that SCP 591 isn't
dangerous like any piece of vintage
technology the components of the
pretendo system have degraded over time
their functionality steadily decreasing
for an ordinary game console this would
be a simple inconvenience something that
would impact the quality of the graphics
or responsiveness of the controls it
would be annoying and maybe eventually
unplayable but otherwise harmless for
the pretendo however this degradation
has had catastrophic events when a game
cartridge is inserted into SCP 591 there
is now a chance of the CK class reality
restructuring scenario going wrong and
resulting in a ZK class reality failure
scenario instead essentially instead of
just transporting the player into the
world of the Game reality will crumble
in the designated area and the laws of
time space and physics will be bent or
even broken while the CK class scenarios
dissipate as soon as the console is
deactivated the ZK class scenarios
refuse to play by the rules they remain
in place wherever they first manifested
seemingly permanently the ZK class
scenarios were first observed during
play testing by the research staff
assigned to SCP 591 after learning about
the nature of the pretendo game system
Dr Furukawa has volunteered as a test
subject specifically requesting that he
be given the chance to play the Dr
Wonder tainment title The Legend of
swordmaster because quote it just looks
really cool this particular game came
with not just the cartridge but a
special sword-shaped controller to be
used during the sword fight SE sequences
Dr Furukawa stepped into the containment
cell where one instance of SCP 591 had
been placed with his chosen game
cartridge and controller waiting for him
as soon as he inserted the cartridge
into the console and pressed the start
button the room around him began to
transform reality itself warping and
reshaping to fit the world of the game
fluorescent lights and stark white walls
were replaced by pixelated trees and a
winding Cobblestone path leading to a
massive Stone Castle the first enemy a
knight in black armor leapt into frame
and Dr Furukawa raised his sword ready
for combat but before he had a chance to
deal the first blow it became clear that
something wasn't right the enemy Knight
suddenly disappeared glitching out of
sight the Cobblestone slowly began to
drift into the air and so did Dr frwa
just as suddenly as he lifted off he
dropped back to the ground with a heavy
thud gravity was rapidly fluctuating and
he could scarcely keep his balance in
front of him he could see random cubic
structures popping up out of nowhere
made of wood Stone and ice and the game
he called out desperately pull the plug
someone please outside one of the
researchers watching The Experiment cut
the power to the console but nothing
happened the world refused to return to
normal security officers entered the
area and attempted to remove Dr Furukawa
but found that his body still resembled
an 8-bit video game character when they
attempted to drag him out of the ZK
class zone he cried out in pain as his
body began to dissolve into static they
had turned off the console but they were
unable to pull him out the rest of the
research team horrified by what they had
witnessed began to take measurements of
the reality failure scenario from
outside of the room the area now
displayed a complete absence of
naturally occurring radiation including
cosmic background radiation there was
also evidence of time dilation reduction
of light speed and the gravity
fluctuations that Dr Furukawa had first
noticed with no way to remove futakawa
from this broken reality the area would
have to be sealed off and he would be
left inside there was no other option so
they constructed a concrete Dome around
the testing site and relocated the
remaining instances of SCP 591 from that
point on testing was only conducted
using DCL classes no matter how much
research staff loved video games or how
vehemently they insisted that they were
quote willing to roll the dice they were
barred from testing and encouraged to
pick up a VR head set for a much lower
risk immersive gaming experience over
the years of testing following the Dr
phawa incident four more ZK class
scenarios were created and contained
some of the individuals survived the
incident but were physically altered so
greatly that they would not be able to
survive outside of the ZK class reality
failure the only people who survived
were unable to readjust to their lives
continuing to live as the main character
of the game that they were playing at
this point testing was officially
suspended Ed indefinitely due to not
only the loss of human life but also the
unpredictable and highly dangerous
nature of the damage being done to
reality on such a grand scale all
instances of SCP 591 confiscated by the
foundation are kept in a storage
containment Vault kept separate from any
civilians or their infrastructure by a
distance of at least 500 M it is also
kept separate from other Foundation
controlled containment facilities unless
it is being used for official approved
testing by level three staff it is to
remain deactivated at all times any ZK
class scenarios created by an instance
of SCP 591 will be contained via the
construction of a closed concrete Dome
and given the designation of sector W
number sectors W1 through W5 the
currently existing ZK class scenarios
are monitored remotely and kept highly
classified any Personnel or test
subjects located inside one of these
sectors will remain there indefinitely
and be officially considered Lost In
Action any any additional instances of
SCP 591 located in civilian stores
households or any public place are to be
removed and contained indefinitely as
the years have gone by testing has
indicated a steady increase in the rate
of ZK class scenarios being generated
from a CK class scenario where it was
only a 1% chance there is now a 32%
chance according to Entertainment
Company record seized during a
foundation raid of one of their toy
factories there are still plenty of SCP
591 instances out there in the world
just waiting for some unsuspecting gamer
to fire them up and get lost in the
story literally if the documents found
are accurate there are around 243
consoles and 1300 consoles still in
circulation these Also may or may not
include a pocket pretendo model that was
developed as a prototype but never
officially released on the market if it
was and the chaos of the pretendo system
is available in a portable form well
it's best not to think about that for
too long the foundation is doing its
best to track down the remaining
pretendo systems but there is no way to
know for sure what distant corners of
the world they've made their way to so
when you're picking up a shiny new game
console or a nostalgic vintage model to
relive some of your favorite childhood
memories with take an extra close look
at the label and make sure you're
getting the real thing because if you're
not careful it just might be game over
for many Avid video game fans those who
just can't get enough of grinding away
for hours on quests battling endless
enemies and exploring infinite Virtual
Worlds Landing a job as a gameplay
tester seems like the perfect
opportunity doing your favorite thing in
the world and getting paid to do it well
that's the dream plus the added benefit
of seeing how the sausage gets made of
getting access to a game still in
development and suggesting ways it can
be improved think of all the gaming
disasters that might have been avoided
with a few more play testers in the room
looking at you follow Out New Vegas and
your NPCs with the spinning
heads well One Gamer had the same
thought a young man by the name of Danny
wheeler when he spotted an ad seeking
beta play testers for an in development
RPG from an upand cominging indie game
Studio he jumped at the chance to apply
the pay wasn't amazing but it was
definitely a better gig than his current
job at the local convenience store
Hawking energy drinks to snarky teens
and counting down the hours until he
could get back home kick up his feet and
get away from it all with a controller
in his hand but sometimes things that
seem too good to be true actually are at
first Danny had a perfectly enjoyable
time testing the game it was standard
RPG fantasy fod and though he made sure
to inform the developers that he found
the steampunk aesthetic to be a little
bit played out at this point there was
nothing at all notable about it it was
fine but the development team kept going
on and on about the Tactical heuristic
algorithms and how the game was meant to
learn the more the player played so Dany
was instructed to log as many hours of
this exceedingly average game as
possible he sat at his desk for hours
sipping on an extra- llarge soda and
clicking away fighting Orcs goblins and
more slowly the difficulty began to
increase and the game started to grow on
him a bit he even developed a favorite
character to play as the Rogue with his
stealth and proficiency for close-range
combat the more he played as the Rogue
however the more he started to know no
the game's characters behaving
differently enemies were attacking him
with ranged weapons from far away they
were setting traps to ruin his character
stealthy approach and catch him in the
ACT then the game started to glitch a
lot to the point of becoming nearly
unplayable enemies would fall to the
ground as if Dead when he hadn't dealt
them a single blow as he started to walk
his characters away from them they would
suddenly spring back to life and strike
before he could even think about a
defense if he didn't know any better he
could swear the game's characters were
deliberately trying to trick him it only
got more frustrating from there with
enemies making sudden loud sounds to
catch him off guard and startle him out
of concentration and other characters
staring down the barrel of the camera
with serious unblinking eyes as if they
could see him through his monitor one
day he fired up the game to see that its
characters somehow had rearranged
various torches to spell out you'll
never amount to anything Dany your dad
was right it took a ton of torches and
Dany couldn't help but take it
personally that was the last straw he
returned the game to the studio and
resigned from his position he got enough
insults working in customer service he
didn't need to take that kind of talk
from a video game though he didn't know
it Dany got out not a moment too soon
other play testers were not as lucky
particularly One Man Who Would sadly
lose his life as Danny inted this was no
ordinary video game it was unusual
enough to draw the attention of the SCP
Foundation who would go on to designate
it SCP
1633 SCP 1633 is an anomalous computer
game created by a now defunct
independent game Studio the copy
currently being held by the foundation
is believed to be a beta version of the
game while the core gameplay is
relatively complete there are numerous
missing assets the music is largely
either missing or placeholder music and
the game is plagued by a large number of
graphical glitches because of the
generally buggy and glitchy nature of
the game the foundation considered both
Todd Howard and CD project red to be
major people and groups of interest in
the case however the discovery of other
key suspects eventually absolved them of
Suspicion for now this version of the
game was compiled 2 days before the
foundation raided the office of the
studio and is therefore believed to be
the most complete version of the game in
existence to be more specific about the
actual nature of the game itself SCP
1633 is a squad-based RPG with a
third-person camera perspective the
action is seen from an elevated
perspective with all characters on
screen aesthetically the game world is
steampunk and features various fantasy
creatures as enemies including elves
dwarves Orcs goblins Etc fitting with
the steampunk style the game's urban
areas are modeled after Victorian era
London the four-player characters are a
band of Outlaws hired by the Sinister
Arch Duke of bodri to investigate a
theft however as the game progresses it
becomes a battle to save the entire
world as an ancient all powerful being
known as Kar intends to wake from its
Thousand-Year Slumber and Destroy
Humanity the player controls a squad of
four characters with direct control over
one character at a time and a command
menu to control the other three It is
believed that in the game's finish State
a multiplayer option that would have
allowed four different real world
players to cooperate is likely to have
been included like many squad-based
games each character has has a different
specialty The Marksman uses longrange
weapons The Alchemist has access to
potions and chemicals with various
effects the Rogue can move stealthily
and assassinate enemies and the thug has
greater Health than the other characters
and does more melee damage and as is
also typical for games of this variety
XP earned from completing challenges and
killing enemies throughout the game
allows for players to upgrade the
abilities and stats of their characters
while the story and core gameplay
mechanics are nothing special there is
one element that pushes SCP 1633 into
anomalous territory and it's also the
element that would have been front and
center in a Finnish games marketing
campaign it's quote tactical heuristic
algorithms these work in a unique
fashion whenever a player finishes a
session and saves their game the game
will begin running lengthy background
processes when these processes are
complete a ptd or player tactical data
file is saved on the computer when the
save file and by extension the
associated ptd file is loaded the
enemies and challenges in the game will
have become far more effective tailoring
their methods to the particular skills
and tactics of the player the extent to
which this happened is proportional to
the amount of time spent playing the
game this kind of Technology may seem
theoretically possible but the extent to
which the game pushes it causes it to
rest in anomalous territory the game's
programming is so intelligent that I can
tell simply by the tiniest clues in your
play style if you're loading a file that
isn't your own it will then pause the
game and make you load your own save
file and the tactics employed by the
enemies in the game as they learn more
about the player are nothing short of
frightening at first the enemies will
adapt to the player's preferred weapons
strategies and overall play style then
they will realize that the player
character is controlled by an external
Force meaning of course you and begin to
mount psychological attacks directly on
the player through numerous tests the
foundation has been able to build a kind
of framework for the average player
experience through this framework we're
able to track and correlate average play
time with the average adaptability of
SCP 1633 to the player it is worth
noting that these effects do not apply
if the game is completed in a single
continuous playthrough for the purposes
of this experiment the game was stopped
saved and restarted at regular intervals
allowing the game to collect players
tactical data during the first 2 hours
the game's AI is abysmal with enemies
simply charging at the players with no
strategy whatsoever and typically being
mowed down however from 2 to 5 hours the
enemies undergo intelligence growth
adapting their play style to the types
of weapons they carry and their
environments at this stage this combat
level is also about equal to an
untrained human civilian from 5 to 8
hours enemies become considerably more
proficient and then begin countering the
player on their specific play Styles and
techniques for example they will attack
a player who uses long-range Weaponry
from cover with grenades or Splash
damage weapons to force them out into
the open they will also fully utilize
their environment for both defensive and
offensive purposes laying traps and
creating ambushes to surprise and kill
players at this point their combat
skills are equal to trained soldiers
from 8 to 12 hours the focus of the
enemy shifts from attacking the player
character to attacking the player
directly they engage in behaviors that
from an online playing perspective would
be considered griefing such as
intentionally blocking the player's view
or movement within the game enemies have
also been known to exploit player
expectations pretending to be broken or
glitched to make the player let their
guard down and then killing them in one
play session the enemies began throwing
day flash spells similar to real life
flashbang grenades at at the player they
throw them in a manner that created a
strobing effect causing the player to
have a Grand Mall seizure Beyond 12
hours the enemies engage in advanced
psychological tactics against the player
with methods that range wildly and tend
to be specific to the player's mindset
and play style for example one player
likes to exert a high level of control
over all four of their squad members in
response enemies used attacks that did
little or no damage but caused the
characters to become dazed a state which
temporarily disrupts player control
however rather than attack the dazed
characters enemies simply surround them
in a crowd continually using da attacks
to prevent the player from doing
anything this caused major frustration
for the player enemies may also attempt
to induce psychological Terror among the
players in one example enemies somehow
kidnapped one of the four player
characters and dragged them off screen
when this character was later found they
were strapped to a kind of sacrificial
altar this caused considerable anxiety
for the player it seems that this is the
upper limit of the game's anomalous
powers in most cases meaning things
typically level off after 12 hours
unless a specific entity appears to be
inhabiting the game which you'll learn
more about later in order to discover
the prior information the SCP Foundation
performed a series of tests on the game
with various different subjects in test
001 Junior researcher Ross an
experienced gamer who was pivotal in
first overing the anomaly skipped ahead
of the typical preliminary d-class tests
seeing as he was already eager for the
game's nonanomalous release he was also
eager to be the first in line to try it
out on the foundation's dime being a
gamer Ross also found a number of
glitches and exploits in the game to
improve his performance allowing him to
run rings around his enemies however as
expected the enemies adapted to ross'
techniques after Gathering his player
tactical data first they just began
using their weapons and exploiting the
environments more effectively but they
didn't stop there soon they became aware
of the same exploits Ross was using
before exploiting them themselves and
using it to beat him repeatedly in the
end they moved to the psychological
stage forcing Ross into a glitch that
rendered him unable to move he tried to
free his character for several minutes
until realizing he couldn't and rage
quit the game in test 002 they used a
d-class designated d22 930 he was a man
with proven anger issues even down to
murdering his prior girlfriend in a
jealous rage initially he enjoyed the
game choosing the thug character type
and taking out his aggression on the
many enemies however as time went on the
enemies became wise to his tactic and
began their psychological attacks they
gathered around the DCL class's player
character dropping their weapons but the
Swarm became so tightly packed around
the character that he couldn't even move
this started to cause major frustration
when the character attempted to charge
through the enemies attacked killing him
with their bare hands in test 014 the
foundation brought in an agent with
special forces experiences with Advanced
knowledge in tactical combat however
even she was worn down and defeated over
time as the enemies adapted to and
exploited her tactics the foundation
even considered using SCP 1633 as a tool
for developing effective countertactics
in their real life off operations in
test 021 the foundation used a d-class
with vast experience in the world of
commercial gaming he was told to
complete the game in one playthrough
taking pauses rather than proper breaks
as predicted with no time to run the
background processes and create player
tactical data files the enemies weren't
able to improve and the d-class was able
to complete the game in around 13 hours
however the game did create a player
tactical data file in the aftermath of
this playthrough and and used it to
offer a new game plus mode to the
d-class when he began to play this new
game the screen displayed a seemingly
random pattern of black and white pixels
visually similar to television static
this image appeared to be Cognito
hazardous as it caused Catatonia and
later death for the player and what felt
like a decidedly Petty move for SCP
1633 as alluded to earlier the game was
first discovered by Junior researcher
Ross who was an avid follower of the
independent game Studio initially
producing the game however while
frequenting developer fan forums he
found that various members of the team
were quitting the project for seemingly
bizarre reasons well this wasn't enough
on its own for the foundation to
intervene it was what first attracted
official attention they moved in after
the death of Gregor Tilman a game tester
for the company who died not long after
joining the project the foundation moved
in and after that gained control
shutting down the studio and taking
everything they had all anomalous
elements were isolated secured and
contained any loose ends were given
amnestics and recorded data on the
anomalous artifacts were destroyed it's
believed that one classified female
member of the dev team was behind the
anomalous nature of the game but she was
able to escape and has since attempted
to join other development teams she is
now considered an active person of
interest and is being pursued by mobile
task force mw6 AKA don't hate the player
some final disturbing details are
recorded in a note left by the game
tester Gregor Tilman the note seized by
the foundation and included in SCP 1633
official file reads as follows I'm
writing this on paper cuz I don't think
he can learn it he got everything
digital real quick but I've unplugged
the router and broke my phone so I think
he's trapped in here but he won't stop
talking talking talking all the time at
the start of this job they told me all
about the Tactical algorithm stuff but
man I've been playing games all my life
and I knew knew I could beat it I I knew
I could handle this when I started
playing the game they learned quickly
they kept using the sniper rifle and
after like an hour they learned how to
use cover then another couple hours
they'd set ambushes then another hour
and they started sniping back while
having a different Squad flank me after
that they figured out how to glitch the
physics engine and ride crates at me or
duck under the floor they were learning
but all that was just easy stuff it was
Evolution man one bit figures something
out so it survives longer than the
others
it wasn't directed after act three kraar
shows up he's supposed to be like this
Lovecraft Cosmic horror Crazy Monster
who can read the player's mind and
corrupt your soul he showed up right
after I killed strick the blood Drinker
that big spider monster he's supposed to
have this long speech about how I killed
his General on this plane and now he
needs to intervene directly or something
but instead he talked about how I was a
worthy adversary but I was cheating
because I was on another plane cnar
wasn't like the other enemies because he
wasn't supposed to to be he was supposed
to be smart he was supposed to know
everything so he did he'd been watching
his minions fight me the whole time and
he knew everything they did it wasn't
just random mutations anymore it was
planned it wasn't Evolution man it was
actual intelligent design I brought it
home I had to know more I'm sorry but I
had to I copied the latest compile and
installed it on my home box and brought
my save game and that other file with me
on a flash drive it was the same there
he kept talking to me about how I was
keeping him from fulfilling his purpose
by keeping him trapped in a glass jar no
matter where I went in the game he kept
shouting and ranting then he did more at
first it was just slowing down in my
other programs the drive chugging when
it shouldn't be then the next time I
played the game he started talking about
my screen plays all the enemies look
like me I guess he could see through the
webcam he started needling me about
Jenny reading me bits of her emails
acting out the breakup he found the
videos of her and started making the
enemies talk in her voice then he was
everywhere in my computer I uninstalled
the game but he was was still there he
kept opening documents and typing to me
calling me a foul cheat and a lowly worm
telling me to fight him on the same
plane as soon as I realized he was
outside the game I shut down my router
pulled out the network card but I don't
know if I got them quickly enough maybe
he got out I turned the computer off but
he kept turning it back on I wanted to
break it but I didn't know if that would
kill him maybe it wouldn't maybe it
would let him out I tried leaving the
house but it was like I could still hear
him I couldn't leave him alone because
he might get out or do something else I
can't sleep haven't slept since he came
out I've been here for 3 days and I
can't leave I can't leave him he keeps
telling me to release him but I can't I
want to kill him but I don't know if I
can I I can't think anymore I have to
kill kill kill him before he does
anything new he won't stop talking and
he I can't keep thinking I can't keep
going I'm sorry I have to go now I'm
sorry I'm sorry after studying the note
carefully the foundation conducted a
thorough investigation for any other
manifestations of this cnar entity no
mentions of it were found on any of the
other devices in Tillman's apartment nor
did a web search on the subject turn up
any relevant results at this time it is
believed that the entity whatever it was
or whatever it was attempting to do was
destroyed along with Tillman's computer
which he appeared to have taken apart
smashed and burned in a metal trash can
whatever tormented him during his last
days on Earth is gone now thankfully
because the foundation currently owns
the only copy of the game and the game's
anomalous effects are only evident to
active players SCP 1633 poses no risk of
containment breach and therefore it has
been given the object class safe one
copy of SCP 1633 is stored on a standard
DVD ROM in a secure storage locker in
site 15 along with all supporting
documentation and ancillary materials
any playthroughs of the game must be
approved by project head Dr Burger and
all said playthroughs are to be
monitored closely and subject to strict
rules after all this is one game that
doesn't play fair scp096 the shy guy
woke up in an unfamiliar room without a
thought in its head however one thing
quickly occurred to it this was not its
containment chamber no the solid steel
Cube that had kept it locked up for
decades now didn't have a front desk or
walls covered in strange childlike
murals or tinny party music playing over
old speakers wherever scp096 had found
itself it certainly wasn't the place it
had come to call home if it could read
it would have registered the words
behind the front desk painted onto the
wall band Ban's kindergarten where Joy
Comes Alive little did 096 no something
really did come to life here at band
band's kindergarten but it definitely
wasn't
Joy scp096 was typically used to a much
more confined space so presented with so
much strange Freedom its natural
instinct was to wander around whimpering
quietly to itself this place was
certainly peculiar with multiple large
reinforced doors each one having a large
red button fixed to the wall above them
a strange green creature was painted on
the wall with an a fixed speech bubble
that read jumbo Josh says eat fruits and
vegetables if you want to be strong like
me though 096 paid no mind to such
things this place looked like an SCP
Foundation containment facility mixed
with an offbrand
chuckecheese and some tiny part of the
Shy Guy's dim and dismal brain wanted to
see more of it what other Secrets could
it hold the shy guy pressed one of the
big red buttons causing the doors to
open underneath it there was a faint
sound of childish laughter somewhere
down the distant Hall how had it ever
found its way into such a strange place
the deeper the shy guy wandered the more
strange murals it saw on the wall there
was one for a large orange cartoon
jellyfish with one staring eye where the
speech bubble read Stinger Flynn says
having many arms allows me to help a lot
of people then a squat blue gorilla
likee creature with sharp lower teeth
had a speech bubble that read Captain
fiddles says ugaa boaa a white feminine
catlike creature had the spe Beach
bubbble van bolina says kindness is free
so sprinkle it everywhere a misshapen
pink bird creature had the speech bubble
Opa bird says laughter is the best
medicine so make sure to smile and of
course most importantly of all presiding
over the creativity room was a mural of
a grinning red creature wearing a pair
of party hats on its head like horns his
speech bubble read ban ban says sharing
is caring your pancreas is mine a
whiteboard not far from this mural had
the words run for your lives hastily
scrawled onto it to anyone but the shy
guy who had no point of reference this
was clearly not a normal kindergarten as
the shy guy passed into the hallway
slowly lumbering along it suddenly felt
an intense Spike of burning pain right
through its forehead Rising like a fever
pitch the shy guys subdued whimpers
quickly escalated into horrifying whales
of animalistic rage
this could only mean one thing somewhere
something had made the terrible mistake
of gazing at the shy guy's face in fact
not 10 ft away the unfortunate Opa bird
had made that very mistake it typically
peaked out from behind one of the
hallways pillars to get a good look at
any potential Intruders or new prey
wandering into its midst but this time
the beastly Bird's curiosity had taken
it from Predator to prey itself though
it wouldn't real realized this until it
was already too late as the mutant bird
creature scattered back into the
cavernous Hall filled with plastic trees
and an underwhelming play area the shy
guy came Galloping after it on all fours
roaring with Fury the opala bird was
shocked to see the creature giving chase
this doesn't make sense I meant to chase
you you're not meant to chase me but
things are rarely fair when it comes to
the shy guy arguably one of the most
dangerous uclid class creatures ever
kept in Foundation containment the opala
bird flapped desperately towards the
boarded up escape hatch but the shy guy
was so much faster he grabbed hold of
the bird gripping it in its iron
clutches and began to stretch open its
bottom jaw with a blood curdling Roar
we'll spare you the details of what
happened next but suffice to say little
more than a handful of feathers were
left after finishing off the opala bird
the shy guy reverted from Rage back to
pitiful sadness this place was no better
than the SCP Foundation there were still
creatures here to look at its face and
drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress it was horrible the
shy guy needed to find a way to hide
himself away again so he decided to tear
away the planks covering up the escape
hatch and loed down the narrow Hall and
there the shy guy actually found
something to its liking two platforms
one on either side of the room with what
seemed to be a deep dark Chasm between
the two for most there was an electrical
lift system for carrying them between
the platforms but the shy guy had no
interest in the platforms he only sought
the darkness below where nobody could
see his face that would suit him just
fine the shy guy jumped over the
guardrail and plummeted down below into
the dark feeling the air against its
cold gray skin as it fell felt wonderful
it dared to think that it might even
find solace in this deep dark place but
as soon as he hid something solid some
kind of metal lift system alarms went
off and flashing red lights soon made
everything down there in the darkness
visible to be exposed like this while it
thought it was hidden was the dreaded
Shy Guy's worst nightmare little did he
know he would soon become the worst
nightmare of a number of other beasts as
the shy guy crawled off the metal
platform hoping that perhaps it could
find another place to hide down here its
hands and feet splashed into shallow
water had something sprung a leak down
here the shy guy began wandering the
half dark as the water of this flooded
sub basement area pulled around him it
had no idea that another creature was
already sneaking up behind it getting
ready to strike before 096 could even
react several whip-like orange tentacles
wrapped around its Limbs and began
delivering an antagonizing shock through
its body more tentacles came in soon
after wrapping around the shy guys's
body and face delivering shock After
Shock after After Shock with its
millions of tiny venomous Stinger barbs
for a second it seemed like the surprise
attack might actually be able to subdue
the monster but little did the shy guys
attacker the Monstrous real Stinger
Flynn know that attacking it was just
another way to activate its Infamous
rage State the second that Stinger Flynn
relented even just for a moment the shy
guy grabbed him by the tentacles and
slammed him into the watery floor again
and again and again until the grip of
his tentacles loosened around the Shy
Guy's body and he was defenseless with
stinger panicked and immobilized the shy
guy released the full force of his
Supernatural Fury striking the Demonic
jellyfish with his fists until what was
left couldn't be distinguished from the
water it used to be floating in Stinger
Flynn had been completely annihilated
the shy guy once again temporarily
returned to a state of calm and wandered
out of this watery basement into a
nearby hallway where everything was
bright and dry the walls were painted in
garish childlike drawings of a jungle
with janky looking animals the shy guy
paid no mind to any of it all he wanted
was to find somewhere that he could
actually be alone and away from prying
eyes of all these freaks this dream was
shortlived because as soon as the shy
guy found a new room a wide open
Auditorium filled with inflatable jungle
trees like a crude play area he was
being stalked yet again a powerful
muscular Predator with veins stretching
over its bulging muscles and blue skin
it knew that this Intruder had already
killed two of its fellow Garden dwellers
but this time it would put the spindly
pale Stranger in its place the shagi
heard something rumbling towards it from
behind and turned upon hearing the blood
curdling war cry of ugaa boaa it was the
gorilla like Captain fiddles with
strands of saliva hanging from his tusks
he leaped onto the Shy Guy and began
pounding into its hideous face with his
huge blue fists Captain fiddles would
destroy the shy guy pound him into the
concrete until he stopped moving the one
thing that Captain fiddles didn't expect
was for the shy guy to start fighting
back and he was about to learn the hard
truth that the shy guy could fight a lot
harder than him the scp's spindly but
immensely powerful arms grabbed Captain
fiddles by the shoulders and threw them
into the wall causing huge cracks to
crawl up towards the ceiling before
Captain fiddles could even think about
wrenching himself free the shy guy
leaped to his feet and bounded over to
him the shy guy grabbed Captain fiddles
by the ankles and ripped him out of the
wall letting his body drop to the floor
and then unleashing hell upon Him
Captain fiddles would have begged for
mercy if he wasn't already dead before
the shy guy could even begin to calm
down a trap door opened in the floor
beneath him dropping him into a new area
a multicolored maze where 096 was
trapped like a helpless r rat with the
body count of an atomic bomb once again
the shy guy didn't need to go looking
for trouble because trouble was already
on its way the pure white catlike ban
bolina pounced from a sharp corner in
the Maze claws Beed she jumped onto the
shy guy latching onto him and Clin
trying to scratch his nightmare of a
face if the shy guy had ever possessed
anything resembling patience he would
have run out long before now he grabbed
van bolina shrugging off the pain of her
claws and tossing her into the darkness
high above she flew off with a cat-like
yell and hit some distant ceiling with a
crunch suffice to say she wouldn't be
back to bother the shy guy again tired
and angry the pale Abomination didn't
feel like wandering through a maze
instead it just charged straight through
destroying colorful wall after colorful
wall when it encountered whatever was
behind this extremely frustrating
afternoon it would destroy it with
extreme prejudice that was almost
certainty after breaking through one
more wall the shy guy tumbled out into a
strange room where a grinning red
creature was waiting for him wearing two
party hats on top of his head this was
no mere Lackey it was ban ban himself
the one behind this nightmarish
kindergarten he stared right into the
shy guy's face with no fear at all
almost like he knew something that the
shy guy didn't and it was true he had no
plan to fight the shy guy himself he'd
brought a champion with him as the shy
guy started to scream and rage all the
boxes behind ban ban tumbled out of the
way as a huge figure Rose a behemoth at
least 50 ft tall with green skin giant
teeth and huge staring eyes it was jumbo
Josh and if the shy guy wanted to
graduate from this nightmare
kindergarten it would need to defeat him
and ban ban the shy guy growled digging
its claws into the ground and preparing
to charge forward challenge accepted you
all know exactly who I am the bald
chemistry teacher looked around at the
men surrounding him in the desert
Cadillacs leather jackets blacked out
Shades the gang members shifted
nervously from foot to foot as the man
bragged openly about what he's done to
build his criminal Empire Walter White's
attention turned back to the man in
front of him a slight sneer played
around his lips now say my name the man
took a moment to reply as the desert
wind blew behind him he seemed to be
weighing his options realizing quickly
that he had lost all control over the
situation you're you're Heisenberg
you're G bang Walter White fell to the
ground dead the characters all around
yeled in Surprise Drew their guns and
started wildly pointing them around the
circle trying to figure out who killed
the great Heisenberg but his killer just
stared in awe from his couch in the
front room as the Netflix show kept kept
playing on the TV had the toy gun in his
hand really done that Josh had admitted
to himself that he had a problem along
time ago but at least being a yard sale
addict was cheaper than just a regular
old retail addict actually in truth he
was also an estate sale addict a garage
sale addict and a thrift store addict
anywhere you could buy people's old junk
for rock bottom prices he would sniff it
out the Saturday that his life changed
forever was just like any other Saturday
day really in the sweaty heat of the
Atlantic City suburbs he hadn't meant to
stop by any sales today but one just so
happened to catch his eye there was a
box marked nerd stuff and he took that
as a personal challenge was this some
old lady's version of nerd stuff or a
veteran dungeon Masters Treasure Trove
the reality was somewhere in between the
two there were a couple of seasons of
Buffy on VHS a copy of the original deos
X and some Legend of Zelda plushies it
hadn't really been worth stopping his
car for except for a little plastic
splash of color that caught his eye Josh
reached way down to the bottom of the
box and rooted around for it there was
no way it couldn't possibly be the toy
he'd spent all his childhood asking for
and never getting but in fact it was a
1985 Nintendo Entertainment System
zapper with an orange grip and Barrel
NES gray Bodywork and the Beautiful font
printed along the side it was
unmistakable he threw a wad of cash at
the old lady behind the table and rushed
back into his car quickly as he could it
was time to cancel his Day plans he had
a childhood dream to fulfill but no
sooner that he had got home and flipped
on his TV the dream Came Crashing Down
around him his old NES the one he'd had
since he was a little kid had sadly
keeled over it refused to power on no
matter what he did so that made his
zapper pretty much useless the best he
could do with it now was would be to
point it at the TV and make pew pew
noises with his mouth so Josh opened up
Netflix and put on an episode of
Breaking Bad little did he know as he
raised the zapper to the screen that he
was actually in possession of SCP
674 nobody would know looking at it on
the surface even the most hardcore
Gamers wouldn't have a clue because you
can fully disassemble clean and
reassemble the zapper and get no
indication that it's anything other than
what it appears to be however as soon as
the gun is pointed at a television
screen or a computer monitor of any kind
it starts to pose a very real threat or
at least a very real fictional threat if
you shoot at the screen whatever media
is playing on it at the time will react
and adapt to what has just happened that
means characters on the screens will
react in accordance with the rules of
their respective universes in a grounded
realistic drama The Gunshot will behave
like any other killing or wounding the
victim with perhaps enough time for them
to give a dying monologue but in an
episode of Rick and Morty the shock
could manifest in any number of bizarre
and creative ways news crews that
witnessed the user shooting a person in
their live report will continue to cover
the incident as if it is part of the
ongoing story if you shoot Walter White
he falls to the ground dead Josh stared
at the screen in utter amazement he
didn't expect the riters to kill off
their main character just like that
wasn't there supposed to be another n
episodes what would they do to fill all
that time as the episode played out it
seemed to mostly just follow Jesse
trying desperately to escape with his
money before it was too late he kept
glancing towards the camera for some
reason with a slide look of fear in his
eyes very strange creative decision
there Josh backed out of the show to
scroll through his continue watching
there was something a little creepy
about how he'd pointed the zapper at the
TV pulled the trigger and perfectly at
that moment a character had been shot sh
time to pick out another show without
any guns and murder for a bit you know
something safe The Familiar meloda tune
filled the lounge as various shots of
Dunder Mifflin employees busied
themselves shredding credit cards and
answering phone calls it never ceased to
make his worries go away seeing the
words the office appear on the screen he
settled into the couch watching as the
characters all gathered in the
conference room for some first aid
training the CPR dummy lay on the floor
with Michael Scott earnestly explaining
to the woman that the victim appeared to
have lost their limbs he laughed along
as the scene descended into chaos as
none of the employees took the training
seriously at all even though he'd seen
this episode countless times it never
got old absent-mindedly he pointed the
gun at the TV and pulled the trigger
bang Pam collapsed on the ground all the
characters Dove out of the way trying to
find cover behind their chairs not
daring to peek out at the camera only
the first aid lady stayed on the scene
trying her best to resuscitate Pam it
cut to a shot of Dwight talking to the
camera sadly he said that it was almost
funny but there was a real heaviness in
the moment his eyes were red like he'd
been crying off camera Josh flipped the
TV off and stared at himself in the dark
reflection was he dreaming he hadn't
just done that had he fortunately for
Josh and for the rest of humanity he had
not killed Jenna friser or Brian
Cranston he hadn't even killed their
characters in the shows at least not for
anyone other than himself Research into
SCP 674 shows that the appearance of
characters being killed off on screen
only exists in the mind of the shooter
for everyone else the office Remains the
Same as it always was unfortunately for
Josh however Pam is now dead in that
universe and will always be whenever he
watches an episode it leaves a real
Shadow over the later Seasons but the
characters apparently managed to do a
good job pivoting into its new darker
tone other shows that have been tested
in research conditions have yielded
interesting results like in Star Trek it
is impossible to actually kill Captain
Kirk instead various red shirts always
just so happen to dive in front of him
or fall into frame at the pivotal moment
with a small Dead Zone on the right hand
side of the screen characters who
witness enough shootings have the sense
to stick to that side of the frame
whenever the shot is on them sometimes
going so far as to plead directly with a
viewer breaking the fourth wall in their
desperation to survive when Josh came
back from a long walk outside he'
convinced himself that what he had seen
earlier was all just some vivid dream a
dream he didn't remember waking up from
but definitely wasn't happening anymore
he'd play some video games that's what
he would do he had decided he would just
play some Super Smash Bros and unwind
anyone who has ever said that sentence
to themselves will know firsthand how
foolish that is not 10 minutes later
Josh had definitely forgotten all about
his dream from before for he was too
busy raging and cursing at the screen he
couldn't stand playing against King
dididi that stupid Hammer move always
got him without thinking Josh snatched
the zapper from the couch next to him
and blasted did right in the face in
classic Smash Bros style the giant
penguin King was launched backwards
flying off the screen in a blast of
colorful smoke but he didn't respawn for
a second his character just stood on the
screen awkwardly before it kicked him
back out to the character's select
screen this time though King Didi's
picture was missing Josh couldn't help
himself he set up a free-for-all match
straight away picking all the characters
he hated to fight against Sonic Mario
Pikachu Bowser link NES even we fit
trainer one after the other bang bang
bang he felt a strange sense of
satisfaction once he'd done his work
great now the character list only had
the fair balanced ones left they just so
happened to all be his favorite
characters too but why stop there Josh
jumped across to Elden ring and marched
his night up through the gate to
Stormville Castle before Margot even had
gotten through his opening cut scene
Josh had shot the boss right in the face
this boss battle that he'd been stuck on
for hours was over before it even
started what could he do now he put on
an episode of stranger things and shot
the demogorgan then moff Gideon in the
Mandalorian and some goblins in Hogwarts
Legacy the clickers from The Last of Us
took a couple extra shots but went down
easy enough he went over to his PC and
killed the Ender Dragon in Minecraft
without blowing up any beds he won a
game of Rocket League 530 after he shot
both cars on the opposing team he played
through doors in Roblox without a single
jump scare he would just shoot any
monster that filled his screen what
could be better he reckoned it was time
for more movies walking back across the
lounge spinning the gun around his
finger like a western he wondered if now
would be a good chance to hunt down all
the legend legendary animals in Red Dead
2 it would certainly make the job a lot
easier if he could kill them all in just
one shot he just need to be careful not
to shoot Arthur by accident but then
Josh sat on the remote the TV flicked
over to an old rerun of Bob Ross just
that he'd been squaring up to shoot he
pulled the trigger before he could react
the canvas was splattered red from
somewhere off camera he heard the
artist's wheezing voice try to comfort
him there are no mistakes just
happy but he died before he could say
another word the exposition gun first
came onto the SCP foundation's radar
when a strange police report was doing
the rounds on an email chain amongst
local authorities they were all finding
a great deal of value from a man called
Josh who had turned himself in at his
local station in Atlantic City for quote
killing like everyone naturally the
police took his report very seriously
for all of about 10 minutes as soon as
they realized he was was talking about
video games TV and movie characters the
whole case turned into one big joke they
sat Josh down in front of a TV and
played him episodes of the shows he was
talking about pointing out characters
still alive in scenes after he'd
supposedly shot them to death but he
seemed to just grow more distressed as
he realized he was experiencing this
phenomenon Alone by the time Foundation
agents tracked Josh down and took him in
for questioning the gun had moved on he
marched it straight back to the old lady
who' sold it to him who had then sold it
on again Josh's full account of events
and description of the zapper were taken
before he was administered Class C
amnestics and allowed to continue with
his yard sale addiction uninhibited SCP
674 was found sometime later in the
possession of a 33-year-old Caucasian
male simply referred to as Mr S A
reclusive man in a neighboring City Mr s
first gained the SCP foundation's
attention through his extremist
political blog in which which he claimed
to have assassinated prominent political
figures news anchors and talk show hosts
while the truth of those claims was
demonstrably false it was clear from the
way he described events that he really
did believe the delusion after being
questioned it was discovered that he had
never left his home instead he stayed on
his couch watching news reports and
firing at any prominent figures that
appeared believing that he was indeed
killing them in the real world despite
claiming that he was using SCP 674 to
prevent a military police state using
the device to assassinate so many
high-profile figures had the opposite
effect on his video reality in his blog
posts he described an increasingly
unstable Global Order martial law and
catastrophic events consistent with the
hypothetical release of two deadly scps
his house was barricaded with security
cameras set up in every direction the
more he had been using the gun the more
the characters and journalists saw on TV
had threatened him claiming that that
the SCP Foundation were on their way to
apprehend him and that he would face
retribution for what he had been doing
Mr s's intended ambush of foundation
agents failed while they appeared to be
dying on the security feeds he had set
up the agents experienced no physical
harm in reality as they apprehended the
man and seized SCP 674 while the
majority of researchers have deemed that
SCP 674 is harmless to all but the
mental well-being of the shooter there
was a notably sinister result to Mr s's
time in Foundation detention alone in
his cell Mr s soon started to engage in
heated arguments with the security
camera set up to monitor him there is no
record of any voices in the room other
than his own yet he seemed to be locked
in a fierce argument all of a sudden Mr
s dropped to the ground Dead with three
38 caliber handgun bullets lodged in his
chest the entirety of his holding cell
was searched for evidence of a shooter
but none was found the position gun
remains in a locked plastic case in
storage site 23 aside from regular
cleaning and maintenance it is used
under controlled circumstances to
creatively gather intelligence about
further SCP activity in the event of the
site being compromised Personnel are
allowed to destroy the exposition gun at
their own discretion should it fall into
the wrong hands rock paper scissors a
simple hand game dating back to the Han
Dynasty of Imperial China it is a
decisive game between two players with
the only outcomes being Win Lose or Draw
we're quite familiar with rock paper
scissors here at the SCP Foundation as
the guards are often seen playing
intense rounds of the game to determine
who will be the Unlucky Soul chosen to
secure one of the various ker class scps
during a given week in most cases this
use of rock paper scissors is accepted
as a largely harmless and Fair Way for
defensive Personnel to arrange their
shifts the reason for this is that the
results of rock paper scissors are
generally random as there are very few
ways for an individual's skill to
influence the game or so one might think
in reality rock paper scissors is a
deeply psychological game and this is
mainly because of its origin as a
contest between fellow human beings the
average human is vulnerable to making
errors and falling into patterns and
with only three options to keep track of
it is entirely possible for a seasoned
veteran of rock paper scissors to
predict their opponent's Choice before
any hands are thrown of course that
opponent may also commit an error of
their own by misreading the other
players actions and thus there is always
a chance for an impulsive decision to
swing the results of the game in either
direction human limitation is the only
skill-based mechanic in the game of rock
paper scissors and that same limitation
is what in the eyes of some holds the
game back from reaching its true
potential that was the case until
someone out there discovered the rules
to an anomalous version of rock paper
scissors being spread through a
mysterious email while all attempts to
trace the email back to its original
sender have left the foundation with
more questions than answers we have been
able to learn more about the differences
between the rules of standard rock paper
scissors and the anomalous version we
have given this anomalous version of
rock paper scissors the designation SCP
4633 and unlike the classic edition
under no circumstances are any
foundation Personnel allowed to play a
game incorporating any of the
alternative rules while the ceiling for
skill and variety is theoretically much
higher in a rock paper scissors match
featuring SCP
4633 the risks to the player far
outweigh any added novelty here is how
SCP 4633 functions during an average
game of rock paper scissors well average
prior to the anomalous properties taking
effect rather than being limited to
using merely rock paper or scissors as
the name of the game implies the players
gain access to a series of additional
hand gestures which upon the act of
being thrown become seamlessly
integrated into both players shared
understanding of the rules this alone
would be bizarre enough but the true
harm caused by SC SCP 4633 is in the
nature of the gestures themselves when
one of the non-standard gestures Allowed
by SCP 4633 is used the player's hands
will change shape in ways that under
normal circumstances would be
anatomically impossible each of these
non-standard gestures is distinct from
the rest with the only commonality being
an unusual tendency for the final
gesture to resemble biological
structures often seen in sea life one
particular gesture might cause a player
to rapidly grow a ring of additional
fingers surrounding a gaping anemone
like mouth in the Palm while another
could result in the player's entire arm
flattening into a fin-like appendage
regardless of how severe a departure
from a typical human limb the final
gesture would be the limbs and on rare
occasions the entire body of the player
using the gesture will quickly and
irreversibly mutate into the shape
required to successfully perform it
while these gestures overwhelmingly
result in forms that would be
distressing to most people the same
cognitive effect that causes the
participants to accept changes to the
rules also appears to apply to the
changes affecting their own bodies to
the players of an SCP 4633 augmented
match of rock paper scissors the
non-standard gestures seem as mundane as
the original Three unfortunately the
morphic properties of SCP 4633 are
practically irreversible with extreme
reconstructive surgery being required in
even the best of cases in all instances
of SCP
4633 surgical intervention is necessary
to prevent the spread of details
regarding the non-standard gestures and
their use usage because of the immediate
shift in cognitive awareness among
participants all that is needed for a
new instance of SCP 4633 to occur is the
faintest hint of knowledge of the
alternative rules it's even been noted
that between different groups of players
the non-standard gestures can vary
heavily or seemingly be created on the
fly as the desire to win at all costs
takes hold here are a few examples of
anomalous gestures which have been
observed during instances of SCP
4633 this list is by no means
comprehensive but it will provide an
insight into how SCP 4633 drastically
Alters the existing mechanics of the
game as well as the physique of the
players the Thor gesture transforms the
user's fingers into barbb tentacles it
beats paper and scissors but loses to
rock Chava folds the fingers of the hand
into the palm and causes them to emerge
through the back of the Palm it allows
the user to throw a second gesture at
after they've seen their opponent's
Choice ashaz splits the hand into a pair
of poisonous Stingers which also produce
a potent electrical current between them
it has been seen to lose to paper but
seemingly of their own will The Stingers
lashed at the opposing player and cause
them to fall unconscious three rounds
later due to the effects of the poison
sha USA beats paper and two other
anomalous gestures loses to scissors
rock and a third gesture and morphs the
user's arm into a Dactyl Clum similar to
the front appendage of a mantis shrimp
the zerov simply causes the player to
grow three additional thumbs on one hand
the final gesture resembles a triple
thumbs up is zorov has not been seen to
beat any gestures and the player who
uses it always seems to go on to lose
the match pakar causes the middle and
ring to recede into the hand while the
pointer and pinky fingers extend to
resemble the ice stalks of a snail or
slug the rest of the hand also becomes
coated in a thin layer of slime which
continues to secrete from within pagak
Mar beats scissors and paper but loses
to rock in another anomalous gesture
known as vianek incidentally vianek
causes the arm of the player using it to
elongate into a wormlike tube that
periodically spews a gout of saltwater
on the opponent when vianek was seen
beating pakar the saltwater appeared to
have some adverse effect on the latter
gesture causing the ice docks to droop
and the hand to shrivel until it was
half its original size another anomalous
gesture is gatho recognized by the skin
muscle and veins of the hand turning
translucent revealing a pulsing red
organ in the interior of the Palm once
gathr has been thrown the player who
used it may call out the name of one
other gesture which can no longer be
used in the current match the ukay
gesture is a bit deceptive as it
resembles Rock when first thrown but
gradually causes the hand to condense
into a lump of inert material not
dissimilar to actual ous Rock the
knuckles as well begin to exude a
superheated mineral substance similar to
molten lava ukay exclusively beats paper
and appears to lose to everything else
many of the gestures on record have no
known name but their function within SCP
46 33's altered rules is clear from the
context in which they were used such is
the case with one anomalous gesture
which caused most of the players hand to
withdraw into a siphon likee opening at
their wrist before the very same orifice
shot out a stream of ink into the
opposing player's eyes while there was
no lasting harm done to the opponent by
this gesture the ink did cause temporary
blindness which persisted until they
were defeated by way of their Rock
losing to paper another unknown gesture
has been seen beating both urav and ukay
this gesture makes the player's hand
resemble the crest and gas-filled body
of a Pacific Mana War these examples are
only scraping the surface of the
seemingly Endless Possibilities that SCP
4633 has to offer as you can see the
anomalous hand gestures can be just as
dangerous within the game itself as the
permanent changes they invoke in the
user while the foundation has done its
best to contain all information
surrounding SCP 4633 there have been
clear efforts by several unknown groups
to push the game into continued usage
over the past three decades instances of
SCP 4633 have seen increasing popularity
in the world of high stakes gambling
Perhaps it is because of the inherent
thrill of watching two opponents trying
to strategically outwit each other with
a countless number of non-standard
gestures but more likely it is part of
the anomalous effect of SCP 4633 that
the game would appeal to those desperate
to risk everything on the slim chance of
Victory this neatly brings us to the SCP
4633 related incident which occurred
aboard the private ocean liner known as
the SS fateful Emma before the incident
the Fateful Emma would sail into
international waters twice a year each
time it would bring along a new group of
passengers seemingly selected from the
underprivileged and downcast sector of
society a great many of these passengers
were convicts with repeat violent
offenses chosen from supermax facilities
the world over the process by which
these inmates were chosen for a voyage
aboard the ship was not dissimilar from
the methods the foundation uses to
acquire new class D Personnel naturally
this was how the research team was able
to be off about the Fateful Emma it
became apparent soon after looking into
the ship's career that the individuals
altered by the effects of SCP 4633 had
been seen departing from the ship on
multiple occasions in remote island
Harbors most of the time the individuals
would also be to the best of their
ability with their metamorphosed forms
carrying briefcases filled with hundreds
of thousands of dollars in cash while
Witnesses tend to write off the strange
appearances of those affected as being
the result of a deformity or injury or
in more pronounced instances dismissing
the encounters as sightings of creatures
from the local mythology it was clear to
anyone familiar with SCP 4633 what was
truly going on these passengers were
being made to play pitched games of rock
paper scissors featuring SCP
4633 for massive sums of wealth and what
was worse the Grand Prize winners were
seemingly being released back into
civilization without the knowledge of
law enforcement of course what the
foundation was most concerned about was
the potential for the large scale leak
of detailed information involving SCP
4633 it seemed that the foundation's
latest faceless enemy had revealed
itself whatever wealthy group of
individuals was pulling the strings
behind the games aboard the SS fateful
Emma it was very likely that the ship
was also well protected by a private
Army of trained mercenaries in a display
of Swift but necessary initiative the
foundation assembled a brand new mobile
task force to be dispatched onto the
ocean liner mobile task force row 52
with the fitting code name r Shambo the
mobile task force would board The Vessel
secretly and use whatever means
necessary to prevent the spread of SCP
4633 and any evidence of the associated
non-standard hand gestures before the
Fateful Emma's next Voyage the
foundation isolated the port where it
would depart from and made sure that the
MTF agents were in position the
operation was co- Captain by agent dubo
and agent Shang both of whom prided
themselves on having extraordinarily
good luck agent duah would stealthily
move the majority of the agents under
his command into the cargo hold below
deck and await agent jang's signal agent
Jang himself would assume the name and
identity of one of the criminal
passengers who was intercepted before
boarding by the mobile task force the
wouldbe participant was subsequently
detained and brought into the foundation
as a Class D personnel as the SS fateful
Emma began to to leave the harbor Agent
J joined the other passengers who had
been gathered together in an enormous
function hall there was little
indication of when the games would begin
and Jang made an effort to keep a low
profile until more information was
available shortly after the ship had
officially arrived in international
waters an eccentric man entered the room
on a walkway that overlooked the rest of
the passengers he was flanked by a pair
of armed bodyguards it was plain from
the man's style of dress and demeanor
that he was both absurdly wealthy and
completely out of his mind he wore a
pure white tuxedo and a scarf that
seemed to have been made from the fur of
a Siberian tiger a pair of Dark Shades
with sequin rims obscured his eyes from
view but by far the strangest aspect of
the rich man was the fact that emerging
from the wrist of his right arm was the
eyeless head of a Mor eel where his hand
should be the man spoke addressing the
entire room welcome passengers new and
old to the SS fateful Emma while you you
aboard this ship your fate is in your
own hands over the next 24 hours you
will have the rare opportunity to play
the greatest game of chance that
Humanity has ever known generations of
people from every continent and every
Walk of Life have given their all to the
Mastery of rock paper scissors across
no the men proceeded to speak unusual
syllables for the next minute straight
without even a pause for breath in his
report agent Jen described the man's
voice as gaining an increasingly loud
hum as his speech continued and that
some of the syllables didn't seem to be
the product of human vocal cords he soon
concluded his string of gibberish and
resumed speaking intelligible language
as is customary we will be utilizing the
Iles toi rules you will Begin by
selecting a single opponent and
challenging them to a best of two of
three match this is a single elimination
tournament and any competitors who
cannot otherwise continue continue to
engage in matches will also be
eliminated by the end of your time here
the luckiest among you will be named the
Undisputed champion of these games and
will be granted unlimited Freedom along
with the cash prize the rest of you will
have to determine your own fat for you
all know what awaits you below may your
hands be ready your minds be sharp and
remember winning is everything with a
flourish of his Mor eel hand the wealthy
man finished his introductions and PR ly
exited the room aent Jang looked at the
passengers surrounding him and saw that
they were already beginning to play Rock
Paper Scissors with each other a few had
already begun using the anomalous
gestures warping their limbs into
hideous subnotica agent Jen gave the
signal to agent duah and the rest of the
mobile task force to begin the operation
their target was primarily the Moray
handed man as well as any other Close
Associates that he had on board they
would capture him alive and interrogate
him in into revealing the mystery behind
this illegal gambling Reign once the
mercenaries were dealt with agent Dub's
team would further command the ocean
liner and navigate it to SCP Foundation
research site 45 to await further orders
as for agent Jang he knew what he had to
do to buy time he would participate in
the ensuing rock paper scissors
tournament and eliminate as many of the
other players as possible this he
believed was the best way to minimize
the number of anomalous gestures that
would be used aboard the ship of course
he himself wouldn't be using any of the
anomalous gestures either opting to
limit himself to the standard three this
could put him at a severe disadvantage
over the course of the competition but
aent Jang knew better than to tempt fate
still being eliminated seemed like
something he may want to avoid even
though the consequences for elimination
were left vague in the strange rich
man's speech he still didn't feel that
it would be wise to put himself in a
compromised position while aboard the
Fateful Emma racing himself for the
worst agent Jang accepted the challenge
of a nearby passenger he was off to a
promising start when he threw a scissors
hand against his opponent's paper
because the matches were best two out of
three all he needed was to win one of
the next two matches and he'd survive
this round then he saw the devious look
on his opponent's face and he knew that
this match was about to get weird rather
than admit defeat a and Jen prepared to
throw scissors again the two challenged
their hands and just D Jang had feared
his opponent threw an anomalous gesture
almost instantly the opponent's hand
took on a multim mouthed pis scene form
which began to spit sharp teeth in agent
jang's Direction fortunately the agent's
bulletproof vest was able to withstand
the impact of the teeth what was even
more fortunate was the fact that the
opponent seemed to be a good sport
scissors beat asz ROK you in said the
other passenger before walking away in
search of their next match curiously the
passenger's transformed arm continued to
fire teeth across the room at random
intervals occasionally hitting and
causing injury to one of the other
competitors agent Jang was grateful that
the body armor he was wearing had been
tested to withstand rapid fire from SCP
127 compared to the raw power of the
living gun the teeth launch from azrok
gestures were practically BB rounds he
had succeeded in not being eliminated
both from the game and generally excited
about his win Jen sought out another
opponent to test his lock below deck
agent duah and the rest of the mobile
task force had just finished facing off
against some of the hired mercenaries
when they entered a room presumed to be
the ocean liners Sick Bay inside was a
Grizzly sight a second rock paper
scissors tournament playing out between
players that had been so thoroughly
transformed by the anomalous gestures of
SCP
4633 that they barely appeared to still
be human it was like a scene from a deep
sea documentary with strange and
unknowable creatures fying for dominance
not within a natural food chain or
competition for resources but within a
seemingly never-ending struggle to win a
game of chance it was Purgatory rock
paper scissors Purgatory agent Duba was
appalled but he knew better than to
attempt to stop these creatures from
doing the one thing keeping them all
distracted the morh handed man was still
somewhere in the ship and capturing him
was far more important the research team
would decide what to do with these
former humans once the ship was Secure
within the foundations custody however
what agent tuban didn't realize is that
some of these creatures were advancing
on his team in nightmarish and une
Earthly voices they chanted rock rock
paper scissors suddenly one of the
Abominations resembled nothing more
closely than an enormous mass of coral
produced Four Arms from within its body
and began to throw anomalous hand signs
towards the agents one of the arms threw
ayag which coated an unsuspecting agent
in hot lava causing him to drop to the
floor in pain Panic du ordered the task
force to eliminate every living thing in
the Sick Bay although not in the sense
of their tournament standing of course
meanwhile aent Jang was on a win streak
in the function hall through sheer luck
and determination he had managed to
avoid elimination while eliminating
several other passengers himself he
began to notice that those who were
eliminated were quietly escorted Away by
the bouncers seeming to have their
anomalous changes treated now it was
only down to 12 remaining passengers
agent Jen knew that it was only a matter
of time before dubba and his team took
control of the ship but feeling Reckless
he challenged one of the remaining
passengers in that moment something came
over him as if his determination to see
the mission through was also compelling
him to win at any cost his opponent
threw pakar and out of instinct Jang
threw vanyan the agent went on to win
the entire tournament but sadly he was
unable to collect the prize money as
during the skirmish below deck the man
with a moay hand had escaped with a
small fortune in a highspeed submersible
his ultimate goals and the scope of the
shadowy group he represented would
remain unanswered for the time being
when the SS fateful Emma finally arrived
at site 45 agent Jen came to his senses
and realized that he had underestimated
the cognitive side effects of SCP
4633 due to the immediately recognizable
anomalous state of both his arms agent
Jen was later contained onite with
minimal security it's believed that
researchers are still searching for a
method to reverse the effects it just
goes to show that winning isn't
everything did you hear that not so long
ago a 5-year-old boy went up against 12
of Russia's greatest chess Grand Masters
and do you know what happened he lost
every single match that's because
winning at chess dear viewers isn't easy
chess is an ancient game of strategy
cunning and skill it's not just about
thinking one step ahead of your opponent
that's not going to be enough make a
wrong prediction and you could end up
sacrificing one of your pieces as well
as vital space on the board but thinking
two to three steps ahead beating your
adversary's moves before they've even
been made now there's a viable strategy
tricky but viable after all if it was
easy we'd all be Queen Gambit level
chess prodigies Eric Matthews had never
been good at the game but he had a
pretty substantial reason to keep trying
and that reason's name was Brian
Matthews his father you see for as long
as Eric could remember his dad had
regarded a high level of skill on the
chessboard to be a sign of intellectual
superiority intelligence was something
that Brian put quite a considerable
value on given that he was a professor
at a university in their home country of
England some of Eric's earliest memories
were of playing chess with his dad
usually on a Friday night when Brian got
home after a week of giving lectures to
the next generation of Scholars
obviously with his son at such a young
age the professor would take it easy on
Eric playing in a much laxer fashion
focusing instead on teaching the boy the
basics of the game and for a time at
least it was good it was a rare time
that Eric and his academic father could
spend bonding after all with his mother
gone his dad was all he had but as the
years passed the game Changed by the
time Eric was a teenager Brian had
stopped pulling his punches on the
chessboard he hoped his son would build
on what he'd learned when they played in
the past using those skills to best his
dad on the board but to Eric playing
chess had never been about a purely
educational experience it was more about
spending time with his old man Time
After Time the young man's pawns fell
prey to Brian's expertly considered and
far more competitive moves try as he
might Eric couldn't best his dad he
tried his best and never sto putting the
effort into every game but thinking too
hard about one possible plan of attack
left him wide open to a counter strategy
from the professor over and over again
he landed himself in Checkmate or made
illegal moves without even realizing it
every time earning criticism and
chastisement from his scholarly father
every game it got worse it was like Eric
could feel his father's gaze and the
weighty expectations behind it with each
move he made across the board there were
so many nights where he wondered if it
would be better to give up entirely to
knock down his own King and concede but
how could he ever find any other shared
interests with his dad beyond the two of
them playing chess it had become a
Lifeline tethering Father and Son
together and to cut it now left Eric
uncertain if he'd sink or be able to
swim alongside Brian he had long admired
his father his achievements in Academia
were impossible to avoid with more
framed certificates hung up on the walls
than there were were photos of the pair
of them together but the shadow It cast
over him made Eric desperate to keep
this one shred of Common Ground alive
Eric wasn't the type to give up despite
how much of an uphill struggle the
situation felt like taking a leaf out of
his Professor father's scholarly ways he
decided to learn the game inside and out
every known move and strategy he would
research the entire history of Chess
itself if that's what it took to play
with the same skill as his dear old de
over the coming weeks Eric checked out
every book at his local library on the
subject beginner's guides Advanced rule
books and even a few volumes on notable
players throughout the extensively long
history of the game along the way a
chapter of a certain book stood out to
Eric it described a chess Prodigy from
Russia who had created an early
mechanical chess device known as the
samurai it had been designed to be a
traveling curiosity and would sit
playing chess games against volunteers
taken from a spectating audience each
one of them having forked over some of
their hard-earned money to watch this
man-made wonder the Russian chess
Prodigy young daughters also had a love
for the game seeing that gave Eric a
Pang of jealousy wondering if those
daughters had as much trouble playing
their own father as he did with Brian
but at least there was an underlying
shred of Hope there too if this father
and his daughters could bond over chess
maybe there was a chance for Eric and
his dad too sadly it's one thing to try
and learn all the facts you can about
Chess it's an entirely different Beast
to put all that information to use and
apply it to an actual game despite
having read every book he could get his
hands on Eric still couldn't best Brian
at the board it was like nothing had
changed his father barely noticed when
Eric tried to replicate move sets he'd
read up on and still managed to not only
counter those moves but check his Queen
in the process so practice Eric thought
after all practice was supposedly meant
to make perfect right the plan was
simple if he practiced his chess moves
enough times and figure out how he could
call on what he' learned then he might
stand a chance at winning when he and
his dad played each other there was just
one hiccup to this plan Eric needed
someone to practice against the only
other person in the house was Brian
meaning it was that hiccup that turned
into a problem almost big enough to stop
Eric in his tracks that is until he went
into his father's la AB it was under the
house itself a sort of su LEL maybe used
as a basement or seller by the previous
owners but since Professor Matthews and
his son had lived there the entire room
had been remodeled into an atome
laboratory not a terribly Advanced one
of course this was the early 9s after
all majority of Brian's time even when
he was at home instead of working at the
University was spent on his own
downstairs in the lab Eric had gone down
there in search of his dad to ask him if
there was anyone whom he knew who he
could practice and develop his chess
skills with but instead what he found
down there was the last thing he
expected to see not that he had any clue
exactly what it was at first the thing
was some kind of bizarre Contraption a
collection of components that didn't
seem to be in any logical configuration
however it was primarily composed of
something that Eric recognized All Too
Well a chest table this one was metal
steel to be precise and seemed to be
hooked up to some sort of computer while
back in the 9s computers were hardly as
common place as they are now Eric had
seen a fair few at school and the
library although this one was different
it seemed old far older than Eric
thought computers had been around for as
far as he knew they'd only really come
to prominence in the mid 80s but this
computer looked like it predated even
that period noticing another part of the
contraption a large steam engine with
the words manufactured by modlay Suns
and field established 1840 engraved on
one side made it seem that this whole
device had been around since the
Victorian era the next part that caught
his eyes was the chest pieces themselves
each one standing neatly in its place on
the board they looked delicate
intricately carved from some smooth
substance for a moment Eric toyed with a
thought of how they could even be made
from bone noticing how each PA Knight
Rook Bishop king and queen were all
about the size of a human finger bone he
dismissed the idea nobody would ever do
something like
that Eric grabbed a sheet covering a
large component hooked up to the mess
lifting it away in a swift pole it
unveiled what was sitting beneath a full
Suite of 18th century Samurai armor Eric
to looked closer at the embellishments
on the surface of the pauldrons he was
no expert on feudal Japan but it looked
authentic enough to be the real thing if
not a very close approximation taking a
look at the collection of audities all
tethered together in his father's lab a
certain detail of all his chess research
came to the Forefront of Eric's mind the
armor that had given it away this was
the samurai or at the very least a crude
homemade version of it that his dad had
put together but if it worked it was
also something to practice against it
didn't take Eric long to start tinkering
with the contraption trying to get it to
work all the while the question of why
his dad owned such a thing kept drumming
up noise in the back of his head had
Brian built it or was this the original
made by that Russian chess Prodigy was
this machine the reason that Eric's dad
possessed such an unbeatable skill at
chess would using it give him the edge
he needed to best him at the game and
earn his father's respect after what
felt like hours upon hours of trial and
error with a machine he could barely
comprehend Eric seemed to have cracked
it as far as he could tell the steam
engine powered the whole Contraption and
could be set to five different speeds
labeled on the side in Roman numerals
the power from the engine was then fed
to some kind of sophisticated mechanism
that was within the suit of Samurai
armor allowing it to move and what
appeared to be a series of
electromagnets that move the chest
pieces and kept them on the board
flicking it on to the third highest of
the five speed levels the machine word
into life the sound of creaking and
grinding of metal filled the lab
kneeling opposite Eric went to make the
first move only to stop himself it
wasn't that he changed his mind about
practicing against the samurai but
because of the speed he'd set it to
determining that the settings might have
correlated to difficulty levels Eric
figured that if he really wanted to get
the most rigorous practice to really
hone his chest moves he needed to commit
fully reaching for the dial he turned
the divice up to its Fifth and highest
speed then made his first move he pushed
one of the bone colored prawns forward
by a single square and waited a split
second passed and the arm of the early
automaton responded with its first
counter move it was quick almost moving
with the same natural fluidity and speed
as an actual human being albeit still
with a little bit of creaking and some
slight Clockwork like stutters but it
worked nonetheless the machine could
play the tension over the first game was
palpable B forming a layer of sweat over
Eric's forehead every wor and tick of
the machine gave the impression that
they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves adding to the
urgency despite this Eric Matthews tried
his best to stay calm this was practice
after all a dry run not the inevitable
game he'd play against his dad with
every move he made his heart drummed
against his ribs uncertain he'd made the
right call each time the robotic hand
cruy knocked over one of his pieces is
away Eric felt a surge of frustration
but told himself to quell it he kept
focused using what he'd researched to
adapt and respond accordingly to each of
the machine's moves until Checkmate he'd
beaten it he might have lost everything
save for a knight a rook his king and
queen but he had won trapped without
anywhere else to move on the board the
metal finger of the automaton conceded
the Game knocking over its own King in
resignation panting heart racing from
the sheer excitement of being on The
Winning Side of A game Eric hurly
gathered up and reset all the pieces he
had to go again not just so that he
could be certain it wasn't a fluke but
to make sure he had what it took to take
on his Professor father back and forth
Eric went with the chest machine over
and over again they were fairly evenly
matched it seemed Eric won the second
game only to be best on the next two but
it was sometime afterward he had lost
count of exactly how many rounds later
that things started started to change
maybe it was the age and condition of
the Victorian era chess computer the
natural wear and tear stopping it from
functioning properly But Eric noticed
that the samurai started to make moves
that were illogical that practically
offered him the upper hand with no
discernible strategy behind them then
its movements became flat out illegal
disregarding the directions and number
of squares each different piece was
allowed to move before long it was
moving them erratically around the
chessboard refusing to cooperate and
forcing Eric to call an end to the days
practicing unfortunately it wouldn't be
the end of the unusual things that would
happen that day did you send me that
weird email was the first question
Eric's dad asked him when he returned
home looking noticeably under the
weather confused Eric said that he had
no idea what his father was talking
about Professor Matthews then went on to
describe what he'd received on his work
computer it had been an email with a
file attached to it named Shak m a word
in Russian that translates to chess
embedded in the email below although it
had taken a long time to load being
opened on a 199s computer there had
apparently been a photo as well it was
rather odd Eric Brian went on quite
unnerving to tell the truth black and
white all sort of distorted and
stretched but it looked like two young
girls one grinning and the other
screaming I've been feeling well not
quite myself since I saw it with that
Brian excused himself stating that he'd
been suffering from headaches and a high
temperature and as a result needed to go
and lay down it wasn't like his father
to get ill Eric thought but of course he
had no reason to assume it was anything
serious probably just a sped of fatigue
after a long day of teaching at the
University no cause for concern if only
that's all it was within a few hours
Brian was completely restless so unable
to sleep that simply taking a nap was
impossible he kept calling to Eric
complaining of the sound of childlike
laughter coming from somewhere in the
house but his son hadn't heard anything
by the time the sun went down Eric was
trying to calm his dad down through a
rush of intense anxiety that gripped him
Brian had been claimed to be
hallucinating seeing the Warped faces of
two girls that frightened him half to
death it was getting late long past the
time that they usually played chess
together but for now Eric's mind was
focused solely on helping his dad for a
while he seemed to be able to calm his
father down only to realize Brian wasn't
settled at all he was awake eyes open
fully conscious but wasn't responding at
all to Eric asking if he was all right
instead the accomplished academic just
stared blankly into space Eric had been
up all night exhausted worried for
Brian's safety and completely clueless
about what was happening to him after a
while being non-responsive his dad
seemed to regain a little bit of
Lucidity once more but his behavior was
erratic take me back to work I I need
need to get on my computer Brian
demanded of his son when Eric refused
that's when his dad got angry and
agitated Professor Brian Matthews was
sadly found dead within the next few
months several months later as the sole
executive of his father's estate and
last living relative Eric had to be the
one to go through his dad's personal
belongings volumes upon volumes of thick
academic books his smart scholarly
clothes the house was almost clear now
save for one thing that was left in the
basement lab flicking on the light
switch Eric looked at the samurai
sitting motionless still uncovered after
their last practice game he'd sold off
the chess pieces to a collector in New
York now it was just an empty Oddity
Eric placed a king on the board one of
the ones that he and his dad had used
when they played each other with a
gentle flick of his finger he toppled it
resigning to the strange automaton and
leaving it there in the laboratory he
wasn't sure how but he had some kind of
gut feeling that this chess machine had
somehow been responsible for his
father's fate of course Eric had no idea
what the device actually was and what or
who lay beneath its woring metal Parts
SCP 1875 is the designation given to
this machine now and has been ever since
the foundation recovered it not long
after Eric sold his father's house they
are able to learn much more about it
than young Mr Matthews or even the late
professor Matthews ever had not just how
to make it work or what its function was
but who had built it and who had been
used to build it although details of his
real name eluded the foundation's top
researchers they were able to uncover
newspaper articles about the device from
all over Russia America and England
dating back to the early 1990s the
Russian chess Prodigy who'd invented it
and toured the chess playing machine
around had used some interesting
components to make his automaton maybe
they were what derived its skill at the
game and its apparent tempor when the
device was made to play at maximum speed
for too long he had used his daughters
to make the machine deep within the
heart of this early form of computer the
two girls brain tissue had been hooked
up to the electromagnets The Machine's
moves were theirs each Pawn or Rook
shifting across the black and white
squares of the board every rule or
strategy their Prodigy father had taught
it all determined how the device played
their minds taken from their skulls were
now the analytical engine of their
father's creation the bones of their
fingers he' carved into chest pieces
over the coming weeks the foundation
naturally ran their usual slew of tests
on SCP
1875 playing multiple games of Chess
against it every time they increased the
machine's five levels of speed until it
started behaving erratically while on
the highest setting shortly after every
member of personnel working on SCP 1875
received a bizarre email ma it contained
a file named with the Russian word for
chess and a photograph of the stretched
distorted smiling and screaming faces of
two young girls faces that you might be
seeing very soon ask anyone who has ever
lived in a small town and they'll most
likely all tell you the same exact thing
the worst part isn't just being far away
from the nearest city or distant from
friends and family it's the boredom that
gets you having so little nearby gives
you so few options for things to fill
your time with for some they get used to
it as they grow old spending their life
in the same tiny Community they either
learn to make their own entertainment or
just get used to the boredom drowning It
Out by sitting and watching TV all day
but others they just can't stand being
bored being stuck somewhere with nothing
interesting to do and ultimately they
can end up getting so sick of it that
that there's only one option leave pack
their bags and hit the road up sticks
and move to a new place far from the
small town they were born in thing is
leaving isn't cheap moving to a new town
a big city or even an entirely different
state is a luxury that costs a pretty
penny some might work and save their
wages until they can realize that dream
of moving away but not everyone has that
much patience some Want to Be Free of
the boredom as soon as they can maybe
they might apply to be a contestant on a
game show chance at all and try to win
themselves a big cash prize sure it's a
hell of a Gamble and a loss might mean
humiliation in front of everyone you
know and more but winning could be your
ticket away from small town living that
might be easier said than done though
not only does someone looking to move
away need to be picked as a contestant
they also need to play by the rules and
actually win the game but as if that
wasn't enough they also have to live to
tell about it for as long as she could
remember cat had always hated it here
her hometown was Tiny too small to
include more than the main street with
few local stores the one school that
everyone who had ever lived there had
studied at and little else of note and
as for things people could do for fun in
the town well as you can probably
imagine the options were severely
limited especially for a group of
teenagers like cat and her friends most
of the time all that she and the others
Leo Ricky and Danny could do to pass the
time was sit in the back of Ricky's
truck and park in the middle of town
watching people and waiting for
something even mildly interesting to
happen not that it ever did the four of
them had a name for the rest of the
town's folk everyone that had lived
there for their entire lives and never
dared to venture anywhere else lifers as
in they were imprisoned serving a life
sentence in this small town never to
escape or move on or make something of
themselves as much as they likeed to
poke fun at those people each of the
group knew that every weekend they
wasted just sitting around the closer
they were getting to One Day become
lifers themselves we need to just go cat
would say trying to Rally the other
three into taking a spontaneous trip
away as a group just up the truck one
day pick a direction and drive until we
find somewhere Ricky and Leo would nod
their heads in agreement and Danny would
talk for hours all about the places she
might like to go to one day but none of
them ever actually made any plans to
leave nobody knew where to start until
they heard rumors about an abandoned TV
studio just outside of town apparently
according to Danny's older brother it
had been there for years just sitting
there completely empty it wasn't just a
small small local Studio either one of
the big National networks had owned it
and used to film there regularly back in
the day why would someone set up a
studio here of all places had been Leo's
immediate response look at where we live
cat replied it's the literal middle of
nowhere the network must have got the
land Dirt Cheap the real question is why
don't we go and check it out what for
Danny asked cats silently gestured at
the cramped Main Street that surrounded
them the place that may as well have
been the center of the known universe to
the four Teenage friends do you see
anything else to do around here before
long the four of them were in agreement
Ricky's truck pulled up in front of
their houses in the middle of the night
and under the cover of Darkness they
drove out towards what was left of the
TV studio this was it they were finally
going somewhere beyond the choking
cramped confines of their tiny Hometown
although whether or not they'd all make
it back was another matter here's a hard
lesson for you kids you can't fight for
life you believe you deserve if you
don't have a little skin in the game
with home a few miles in the rearview
mirror the truck stopped at a chainlink
fence a pair of signs were hanging from
it one welcoming them to the studio
while the other simultaneously warned
them to keep out that this area was
private property ignoring it the four of
them stepped out of the truck and
started to climb the fence throwing
Leo's jacket over the top to avoid
injury beyond the fence was a huge
building almost the size of a Warehouse
with a door marked Studio entrance that
practically invited the Intrepid teens
to open it up and have a look inside
each one of them carrying a torch in
hand the group walked up to the
abandoned studio and gently PRI open the
door trying not to make too much noise
even though they knew the whole place
was abandoned they still didn't want to
attract too much attention and get
caught trespassing the lights were all
dead as cat led the group her hand being
tightly squeezed by Dany next to her the
two boys behind none of them had been
sure what to expect it wasn't exactly
like anyone in the group had ever set
foot inside a TV studio before but they
were met with a narrow concrete walled
Corridor so underwhelming that it almost
made it extraordinary in just how
profoundly dull it was lifting his torch
Leo pointed out some lettering on the
wall that read to tmdg set with an arrow
pointing the four friends further down
the corridor naturally driven by her
curiosity and need to be literally
anywhere apart from her hometown cat
followed the Arrow's direction to
another door pushing it open she stepped
inside her torch light immediately being
blocked by a thick curtain brushing her
hand against the material she started
looking for a parting but before she
could welcome
contestants a voice boomed through the
dark coming from somewhere in the space
beyond the curtain instantly Danny
screamed at the sound almost wrenching
cat's arm off in sheer surprise Before
We Begin The Voice continued I need you
all to tell me are you ready cat shot a
look back at Ricky the friend furthest
behind her fumbling with the door they'd
entered through it was locked he
couldn't get it to budge he turned and
met cat's gaze shaking his head uh sure
we're ready Leo suddenly piped up
calling out to answer the voice before
the rest of the group could turn and
glare at him the curtain around them
lifted so much Bright Light Came pouring
in that it practically daed the four of
them each taking a moment to readjust
when her vision cleared cat saw they
were standing in a huge Sound Stage
blinding spotlights pointing at her and
her friends from somewhere above with
seating area big enough to seat their
Town's entire population in that case
folks you know what time it is came the
voice again talking as if there was a
live studio audience present despite
every chair being unoccupied these four
lucky Challengers will go head ahead
each one looking to take on the victory
as well as a huge mystery prize but only
if they dare to take on the most
dangerous game there was a pause as if
this unseen announcer was waiting for a
round of applause without warning more
lights came on Illuminating the space in
front of the four very confused friends
standing before them was what looked
like part of an obstacle course a series
of four horizontal beams over an empty
space the glare of the was so intense
that even squinting cat couldn't tell
what was beneath it just looked like a
void nothing but total darkness with
four narrow beams Bridging the Gap
between where they stood and another
platform Beyond well what are you all
standing around waiting for the
announcer declared almost mocking the
14s urging them the rules of course
there was another awkward pause like the
voice was waiting for laughter it's
simple the four of you will be competing
to make it through each of our obstacles
make it to the end before our timer hits
zero and you'll be tonight's big winner
but fall behind or cheat and it's out
with you a huge Digital Countdown
illuminated on one side of the sound
stage telling the group they only had 10
minutes to play cat Leo Danny and Ricky
barely had a chance to question what was
going on exchanging quick concerned
looks before the announcer started
urgently counting them down 3 2 1 he
cheered simultaneous ly the four
teenagers felt a presence looming behind
them like a figure was standing just out
of view blocking them from turning back
carefully putting one foot in front of
the other cat started shimmying along
the beam in front of her trying to keep
herself steady while also moving as fast
as she could without falling out of the
corner of her eye she could also see
Dany on the beam next to her doing the
same but finding it a little easier to
balance Leo was having no problem at all
sidest stepping with enough speed to
keep him practically neck and neck with
with cat but Ricky was wobbling every
foot he placed on the beam he felt like
it might give way beneath him but it was
just a game show right sure it shouldn't
even really be running right now but
regardless of why or how the worst that
could happen was that he would fall his
next step missed the beam entirely and
Ricky could feel himself toppling guys
he called out to his friends trying to
shift his weight onto his back leg cat
Danny and Leo all froze and snapped
their heads back to look at him just in
time to see Ricky wildly flailing his
arms his whole body toppled to one side
and he dropped off the beam with a loud
scream not one of them saw him land or
even H it for that matter it was as if
Ricky had just been swallowed up whole
by the Dark Void beneath them his scream
getting more and more distant until it
couldn't be heard anymore oh tough break
talk about falling at the first hurdle
The Voice exclaimed as if what had just
happened was some kind of joke so long
Ricky we hardly knew you staying
perfectly still but clearly distressed
Danny called out Ricky's name there was
no answer cat just stared
wideeye as she heard Leo jump the last
bit of his beam onto the platform Danny
come on cat whispered to her friend who
looked back at her with tears streaming
down her face the pair of them carefully
stepped further along their respective
beams trying to stop themselves from
looking down or at the huge clock
seconds ticking away and putting them
under even more undue pressure reaching
the other side Danny dropped to her
knees unable to hold back her sobbing
kneeling down to comfort her cat looked
up at the sound stage's bright lights
for any sign of who was putting them
through this bring Ricky back she yelled
I'm sorry the announcer replied the game
show bravado dropping from their voice
but you agreed to play he'll be fine Leo
said bet you anything he just screamed
like that to scare us Leo you don't
seriously believe that cat asked as she
helped Danny stand up wiping her
friend's tears away is he dead head she
sobbed I I don't know cat replied
honestly of course he's not Leo
interjected it's a Sound Stage it's not
like this place is dangerous then why
was it abandoned Danny asked Leo didn't
give her an answer either because he was
distracted by the lights coming up on
the next part of the obstacle course or
because he didn't know and wouldn't
admit it ahead of them was a long
stretch of the course forming a narrow
square-shaped walkway wide portions of
the top side were dropping to the bottom
in regular intervals
separating the tight space before
opening it up again every time the
segments lifted up the three remaining
contestants could see all the way to the
other side of the walkway where a new
platform waited for them with Danny
under one arm cat looked at the far end
of the walkway as it disappeared and
reappeared behind the rising and falling
segments then she noticed the timer the
seconds rapidly ticking down but Leo had
noticed it too and turned to look at the
two girls with a determined expression
cat shook her head at him but it was too
late with all his strength Leo shoved
Dany and Cat both of them Landing flat
on their backs on the platform he bolted
towards the walkway as fast as he could
managing to dodge between each portion
pausing as they came down only to run
into the next one as they lifted back up
helping Dany back to her feet cat ran
after Leo he already had a head start
and would easily make it to the other
side of the walkway before the girls so
instead cat held Danny close and took it
slow methodically waiting for each
segment to back up before they went
further into the next safe Zone they
were gaining on Leo who was sprinting to
the Finish between the rise and fall of
the ceiling's crushing weight cat
watched him disappear behind each block
only to see his back when it came back
up he had made it to the platform
opposite panting but otherwise unscathed
when she next lost sight of him that's
when the announcer spoke up again now
now Leo it said that was hardly fair was
it and we all know what happens when you
break the the rules as the segment in
front of her and Dany rose again cat
caught sight of Leo just ahead but it
was what was standing behind him that
stopped her in her tracks two huge
figures each like a shadow without
anything casting it towered over Leo one
of them reached forward and grabbed him
shrouding him in a cloak of darkness and
he was gone just like Ricky he vanished
cat had been so transfixed by what she
had just witnessed that she didn't
notice where she was standing right
under a block that was about to drop
grabbing her hand again Denny pulled her
out of the path of the descending slab
cat felt it brush against the back of
her leg just as the pair of them made it
out on the other end and onto the
platform the last two contestants and
then there were too the announcer
cheered pausing again for a reaction
from the empty room we don't want to
play this sick game anymore Danny yelled
well you made it this far the Unseen
host replied time for our third and
final challenge the final stretch of the
course make it through this and you're
home free but fail Or Break The Rules
like Leo and you'll be
disqualified game over it's okay Danny
cat whispered whatever's next we'll get
through it do you think the boys will
come back if we do her friend asked just
like Leo had cat didn't answer the
lights revealed the last stretch of the
course the final platform was overhead a
net climbing wall in front of them it
was a straight vertical Ascent up with a
wall behind the next and holes in its
surface wasting no time both cat and
Dany started climbing up the rungs of
the thick rope staying level with each
other as they went higher and then
they're off look at them go ladies and
gentlemen the announcer commented still
speaking as if to an audience but it's
not going to be so easy the sharp sound
of metal made both girls gasp as long
spikes shot forward from the holes in
the wall the blades retracted
fortunately having Miss Danny and Cat
this time what what had started as a
simple climb up had become something
akin to a twisted game of whack-a-mole
with each of them trying to avoid
staying in front of the holes in the
wall for too long dodging the spikes as
they went in and out they climbed higher
and higher until cat Danny screamed she
looked over her shoulder only to notice
she was in the lead below her Dany was
calling up to her with a fear-stricken
expression her foot was caught in the
rigging of the net kicking and thrashing
wildly to try and free it cat looked
back up she was almost at the platform
form close enough to nearly reach it
with her fingertips but behind her her
friend was stuck and with no idea when
the spikes would come next shooting out
of the wall cat threw herself over the
edge of the platform and landed on her
back just as she heard the gut-wrenching
sound of the spikes extending ring out
she was beside herself tears streaming
down her face it wasn't uncommon for
people to be overwhelmed to the point of
tears at the end of a game show but cat
wasn't crying with joy we have a winner
the disembodied voice declared barely on
audible to the surviving contestant as
she wept after she'd finished explaining
what had happened to the police a group
of mysterious agents flocked to the
Sound Stage to lock it down stopping
anyone else from getting close to it
they'd found a VHS tape in the mailbox
at the front office of the studio on it
was a recording of a game show a live
audience cheering as one by one Ricky
Leo and Danny failed to complete the
course one of the SCP Foundation agents
had come to interview cat asking her to
recount the whole story on all over
again her account lined up perfectly
with everything seen on the tape then
the agent asked her what her prize had
been after she won a car cat replied the
four of us always wanted to leave home
have you ever had a nightmare that
you're running down a long dark hallway
getting chased by something you can't
see the thing behind you isn't fast but
that doesn't matter you can't run
forever and the thing knows it it is a
patient Predator it toys with its food
at first you move with speed and Rhythm
the metallic scraping noise behind you
grows quieter you run and stumble
through the dark your muscles start to
ache and your lungs burn your pace slows
it's still coming you can hear the
scraping getting louder you start to
Panic it's completely dark you don't
know where you're running or even what
you're running from all you know as you
bump against the walls and the sharp
Corners that Rush towards you is that
you can't run forever you trip fall all
and pain explodes through your legs as
your knee shatters on the concrete
ground that scraping is getting louder
you can barely breathe you can't run
anymore with your injury there's no way
to stop what's coming there is no escape
the scraping is right behind you you
scream and then you wake up your heart
is pounding like thunder in your chest
and your sheets are soaked with sweat
but you're safe you're out of those
awful dark hallways but what if this
this wasn't just a nightmare what if
this scenario was real and there was no
escape from the horror chasing you in
the darkness that's what it's like to
have a close encounter with SCP
1918 a sadistic sentient object that
loves playing Twisted games with its
prey but this monster never plays fair
and even worse it's always just a simple
doorway it may even be hiding behind a
door near you right now waiting to start
a game with its new playmate but soon
you'll understand why some doors should
never ever be opened and why some games
are better left unplayed scp1 1918 is an
anomaly with two parts SCP 1918 itself
and SCP
1918-20 D2 are perfectly tailored to
1918s violent Hobbies nobody knows how
long this anomaly has been operating but
it's probably behind countless
disappearances after all 1918 has a
habit of breaking its toys the nightmare
began in a small town in Maine with a
population of only 226 people but that
population was about to get lower people
in the town began to report strange
noises at night a droning metalon
concrete scraping noise like someone
dragging a lead pipe along the ground at
first people just ignored the sound it
was all in their heads or maybe just a
faulty oven or a washing machine on the
fritz anything that would allow them to
forget about the noise and get on with
their daily lives but the noises were
coming from below they could be heard
out on the streets most audibly near
manholes and Sewer grates people started
feeling unsafe in their homes the noises
were spooking animals and children
people were losing sleep that scraping
they all tried to ignore was beginning
to get to the mall letters emails and
angry phone calls to the Town Council
were piling up something had to be done
before the whole town went crazy with
fear the mayor authorized four utility
workers to investigate the source of the
noise at a local sewage treatment
facility considering the scraping was
loudest near the sewer grates everyone
just assumed that whatever was causing
all this must be connected to the sewers
four utility workers were sent to
investigate the facility only to find
that the Machinery on site was working
just fine the source of the problems
must have been coming directly from the
underground sewer lines themselves the
four workers equipped with headlamps
descended into a long service tunnel
that fed into the sewer system as they
passed deeper into the tunnel the
darkness around them became thicker it
was a tangible presence that drowned out
the light of their headlamps similar to
the anomalous phenomenon exhibited by
SCP 087 when the utility workers tried
to turn back they discovered another
impossibility it seemed that the tunnel
behind them had become a solid concrete
wall they were trapped but where it was
too dark to tell confused and terrified
the four men stuck together attempting
to find a way out it was too dark to see
their hand in front of their face so all
they could do was navigate Slowly by
feeling the walls around them these
walls felt old crusty there was a kind
of faint metallic stench hanging in the
air too like old blood something
horrible had happened here and something
horrible was about to happen again all
they could do was keep moving and try to
stay calm eventually after hours of
pawing at the walls in the dark they
found an open doorway one by one they
filed inside only to feel blinded when
bright white ceiling lights suddenly
switched on the room was all white and
filled with pipes large and small
running from walls wall to wall just
then one of the utility workers let out
an earsplitting scream and pointed
towards the doorway his colleagues
turned and gasped in shock there was
something outside the door and it was
staring at them the object filled up
almost the entire doorway it seemed like
a demonic hobby horse made from a black
and white candy striped metal pole with
a crude plastic head on top the head
looked like a clowns with a wide toothy
grin but no visible eyes
it was SCP
1918 the utility workers were frozen as
the object leaned forward slightly and
slithered into the room the bottom of
the metal pipe scraping against the
ground it was the exact same scraping
noise that had been haunting the
concerned towns folk up above this was
the thing behind it all and as the
object moved its metal poles started to
scrape words into the ground Tick Tac
Toe none of the four utility workers
were were ever seen again it didn't take
long for the SCP Foundation to descend
upon this quiet main town and pick up
the pieces all relevant officials were
provided them N Sticks and cover stories
were created for the disappearances of
the four utility workers the foundation
also commandeered the sewage treatment
facility that held the entrance to SCP
1918-20 was given a uclid classification
due to theix nature of its hunting
grounds and then the real research began
the foundation soon made some disturbing
discoveries entrances into the scp1
19182 area didn't follow any kind of
logic the hunting ground of scp1 1918
can be entered from almost any location
if you're unlucky enough there are
currently nine known entrances including
five sewage grates three utility shafts
located in a sewage facility and one
toilet and these are just the ones that
the foundation knows about there are a
huge number of ways to enter SCP
1918-20 D2 is contained 20 M below the
streets of this unassuming main Town
Personnel aside from Foundation approved
d-class guinea pigs are refused entrance
researchers have mapped out the layout
of 191 18-2 through seismic Imaging of
SCP 1918s movements there are 18
identical room pairs in scp1
198-217 D2 is symmetrical with half a
meter wide path circling each compound
room the only deviation to this
construction are the location of
entrances on the sides of each
individual room which vary randomly
while the location is active what
exactly does does SCP 1918 do in this
private little maze it plays games of
course its two favorites as indicated by
the words it scrapes into the ground are
tick tac toe and memory in tic-tac-toe
198 moves to each one room leaving
behind X markings on the floors if the
room is not already marked with an o in
a manner similar to a game of
tic-tac-toe how a victim is meant to
accomplish making a Mark or
understanding this process is unknown as
no AIDS are given blood is commonly used
by victims to make their markings hence
the rusty smell in many of the rooms in
memory the trapped victim is rendered
unconscious by blunt force presumably
from SCP 1918 the subject regains
Consciousness in a random section of the
facility success is marked by finding a
one room identical to the central room
this event seems to possess a time limit
as the subject is pursued by SCP 1918
through the the halls of the facility
the subject wins by marking the correct
room with an O what happens if you win
or lose these games it's important to
note that scp1 1918 is very competitive
and doesn't play fair if you win the
object will merely accuse you of
cheating and start a new game this will
happen again and again until eventually
you lose and what do you do well take
the horrifying encounter d-class
Personnel member d 2934 had with SCP
1918 wearing video and audio equipment D
2934 was led into SCP
198-217 challenged him to a game of
Tic-tac-toe and Against All Odds D 2934
won the game but 1918 didn't take kindly
to that it accused D 2934 of cheating
carving its accusations into the ground
before challenging him to a deadly game
of memory after hours of chasing D 2934
eventually lost his mind and was backed
into a corner by 1918 as the object made
its way towards him he panicked ripped a
pipe from the wall and began smashing
1918s head as the plastic cracked under
the force of the blows Foundation
scientists could see real brains inside
D 2934 screamed and the video feed cut
off when the video turned back on
sometime later 1918 stared into the
camera with a different head mounted at
top its metal pole one that just a few
hours earlier had belonged to the
unfortunate
d2930 if there's one lesson to be
learned from this terrifying anomaly
it's that there truly Is No Escape from
SCP
1918 you're sitting in the middle of a
cheering crowd the arena around you is
electric fans hollering from their seats
as they watch the basketball game every
Point scored every shot missed and every
skillful pass of the ball sends waves of
excitement over everyone in the audience
Applause shouts and chant fill the air
it distracts you for a moment you find
yourself swept up in the energy of the
game but slowly surely a nagging feeling
creeps up on you as your eyes follow the
ball that feeling turns to a sickening
realization as one of the players jumps
and dunks the basketball scoring another
another two points you notice the look
on his face the same look on the faces
of all the other players on the court a
solemn hopeless expression it's the same
look of Silent despair worn by all the
spectators around you then you remember
you've watched this exact game of
basketball before many many times before
and that is when you feel the same
hopeless expression appear on your own
face realizing just how how long you
have been here watching this game over
and over reminded that you will never
ever leave this Arena welcome to SCP
1733 to the untrained I SCP 1733 seems
to be a completely harmless item stored
in a digital video recorder it is kept
securely in the dusty depths of the SCP
foundation's video archives if any
researcher is given permission to study
SCP 17 33 they will find it to be an
ordinary VHS tape but what about the
contents of said tape does it contain a
bizarre disconnected series of black and
white video clips that when viewed only
give the Watchers 7 days before the
spirit of a drowned girl comes crawling
out of their TV screen to kill them well
not exactly but we're sure that if such
a tape exists the foundation probably
has it under loock and key too the
footage on SCP 1733 is as seemingly
benol as the ordin AR VHS tape itself
when played the viewer will witness a TV
broadcast of a basketball game
specifically the 2010 2011 NBA season
opener broadcast on television and
captured on tape by an unknown civilian
the game took place on the 26th of
October 2010 in the TD Garden arena in
Boston Massachusetts a game where the
hometown Boston Celtics took on the
Miami Heat by now perhaps you are
wondering what is so special about this
particular game and why the SCP
Foundation would be so interested in
keeping a VHS recording of it so secure
is one of the 05 Council secretly a
Celtics fan well that's impossible to
say for sure what we do know for certain
is that SCP 1733 is far more than just a
harmless recording of a basketball game
the SCP Foundation First caught wind of
SCP 1733 existence the day after the
game on October 27th a Boston native
that had watched and recorded the game
made comments on social media about a
technical foul that the game's referee
had failed to pick up on according to
this individual during the third quarter
an instance of unsportsmanlike conduct
took place between Ray Allen and Chris
Bosch the person making these claims was
quickly ridiculed by commenters on the
same thread but then this person
uploaded a clip of this foul from the
footage they had recorded the other
commenters were dumbfounded during the
original broadcast that foul had never
happened but the recording showed it
clearer as day the footage was quickly
expunged and all traces of the clip
removed from the Internet by Personnel
acting on behalf of the SCP Foundation
any that had viewed the video on
Facebook or been a part of the comments
debating this previously non-existent
foul were Tracked Down via their IP
addresses all of them including the
owner of the tape were given amnestics
to wipe their memories of the supposed
infraction and SCP 1733 was returned to
the foundation for further analysis is
researchers at the foundation were
determined to understand the anomalous
nature of SCP
1733 and why the footage contained on
this particular VHS tape was so
different from the basketball games
original broadcast at first the
differences in the game seemed to be
only slight changes from the one that
actually aired on TV a different vou
here a small Point difference there
while the recording of the game
contained on SCP 1733 was slightly
different from the real life game
perhaps even more interesting was that
these differences changed with repeat
viewings researchers wouldn't observe
the same differences every time they
watched SCP
1733 but would instead spot something
different that had been changed each
time they restarted the tapame and as
they continued to watch and rewatch SCP
1733 is footage the true horror of the
video's anomalous properties became more
and more apparent as the footage
recorded on SCP 1733 began to diverge
more and more from the original
broadcast researchers shifted their
attention away from the basketball game
itself and on to the people watching it
just like the specifics of the game
itself the fans in the arena seemed to
also change with every rewatch of the
tape and even stranger the people in the
crowd seemed to not only be aware of
their existence within the footage but
also retain memories of every previous
replayed Vision each time the
researchers had watch watched SCP 1733
the audience trapped within had gained
more and more cognizance every man woman
and child in the audience of that
basketball game began remembering that
they had seen multiple variations of the
same game over and over again this first
became apparent to Foundation
researchers when the game's commentators
two presenters named Mike and Tommy
began to comment on a strange sense of
deja vu they were experiencing as they
watched the Boston Celtics and Miami he
play both seemed to share Notions that
the game they were witnessing was
strangely familiar and in later replays
of the tape these two commentator
personalities were able to recall the
events of the game with perfect Vivid
accuracy while they never addressed the
viewer directly this cumulative effect
seems to have extended to every person
that was present within the arena at the
time that the original broadcast was
recorded everyone from the commentators
to the coaches the players to the
patrons all remember the diverging
versions of the basketball game but seem
to have no awareness that they are
trapped inside a recording on a VHS tape
it should be noted that it is still
unclear whether the entities are real
people or digital copies that solely
resign on the tape every individual
shown to be inside TD Garden on the 26th
of October 2010 seems to be identical to
their counterparts in the real world
each of the basketball players on both
the Boston Celtics and Miami Heat teams
have the exact same level of talent as
they do in reality and their individual
mannerisms are perfectly recreated in
the SCP 1733 footage and the same is
true of the fans in the audience each
one appearing to be in every conceivable
way a living human being but the most
unnerving aspect of SCP 1733 was found
when the foundation agents were tasked
with tracking down members of the
audience who were seing on the tape and
they found nothing unlike the players
and coaches who can quite easily be
found in our world with many of them
still playing or involved with
professional basketball Personnel were
unable to find a single trace of any of
the people from the audience not one
clue as to their current whereabouts or
status it is unclear how but it appears
that everyone shown on SCP
1733 especially those watching the game
unfold from the stands is a person
trapped in digital form stuck watching
variations of the same match on Loop
researchers at the SCP Foundation who
were studying SCP 1733 initially
theorized that the tape had been
designed to display an infinite variety
of different game outcomes given that
the tactics utilized by the players were
different with each playback of SCP
1733 this seemed to be the case that the
tape was showing a what if scenario each
time the tape was rewound and played
from the start but the scenario wasn't
resetting each time it was clear that
they were learning by the 34th replay of
the footage the Boston Celtics and Miami
Heat were so in tune with the O opposing
team's Playbook that both sides players
were able to perfectly and precisely
counter their opponents moves and kept
the score at 0 for much of the game at
this stage in the foundation's research
the players on the SCP 1733 tape had not
yet become fully aware that they had
played the same game already in earlier
playbacks but it is possible possible
that weak memories of the earlier
versions of the same match manifested as
instinctive ways players could counter
the moves of their rival team however by
the time Foundation researchers had
replayed the SCP 1733 footage 45 times
the players their coaches and fans
watching the game had become aware of
what was happening to them it was at
this point that the digital recording
from TD Garden changed dramatically
realizing that they'd been playing the
same game of basketball over and over
over the players refused to participate
any longer everyone in the audience
began to attempt to escape from the tape
where they'd been unknowingly imprisoned
but not a single one of the stadium
doors would budge and neither the fans
nor the players seemed to be able to
leave through any other exit out of TD
Garden over the following playbacks of
the SCP 1733 videotape attempts at
Escape grew increasingly daring in one
playback a full-scale riot broke out in
another makeshift explos explosives were
built and used by those trapped to try
and blast their way to Freedom as their
cognition grew and they began to
remember friends and family from outside
the videotape the crowd trapped in SCP
1733 grew even more desperate players
and their coaches retired to locker
rooms withdrawing from the crowd for a
Time the rest of the people in the
footage began to form factions amongst
themselves one of the more prominent
calling themselves the faithkeepers
these individuals voiced their belief
that they had been confined to T Garden
as some form of spiritual punishment as
a result of the consumerism that is rif
in a post-industrial society the
faithkeepers began burning offerings in
the center of the basketball court
phones wallets car keys anything that
reminded them of the modern world over
the subsequent playbacks of SCP 1733 the
faithkeepers grew in their numbers
indoctrinating more of the crowd into
their movement those still trying to
escape from the stadium were causing
more Dam damage to themselves in their
enclosure with three men caught in the
blast of another crude bomb placed on an
exit door unfortunately for them the
door barely showed a scratch in the
aftermath of the detonation as
Foundation researchers continued
replaying the tape those trapped with an
SCP 1733 descended into depraved AXS and
incidences of violence became rampant
some even attempted to take their own
lives in Acts of desperation jumping
from balcony in the hopes of ending the
loop those that had joined the growing
ranks of the faithkeepers did not engage
in such Behavior instead creating
makeshift curtains to separate
themselves from the breakdown that was
taking place among the others trapped
within the SCP 1733 tape at some point
beyond the 112th playback of the
videotape the faithkeepers marched off
scream and brought the basketball teams
back out onto the main Court they then
began a ritualistic sacrifice disbaling
the professional athletes for their
fellow prisoners to see this had no
noticeable effect with the recording of
the game resetting as it had done in
earlier rewatches in a later playback
the faithkeepers then began to call for
all the children in the stadium to be
sacrificed in the same way testing on
SCP 1733 was finally suspended
indefinitely after this point and as far
as we know the crowd remains trapped
inside the anomalous recording of this
particular Celtic Heat basketball game
Foundation researchers have been unable
to produce the same anomalous effects as
those of SCP
1733 even when using the DVR that
originally produced the recording the
digital video recorder itself does not
seem to imprint the same properties onto
other VHS tapes making SCP 1733 an
isolated anomaly however the next time
you find yourself at a basketball game
it might be worth asking yourself have I
seen this game before now check out SCP
1861 the crew of the HMS winter shimer
and SCP 1337 The Hitchhiker for more
Chilling Tales from the SCP Foundation